TO ORDER GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
THANK YU FOR BEING HERE IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATE
**** AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IT IN HERE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE'LL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO FIVE
NINE OR FIVE THREE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE ONE SEVEN
EIGHT THREE THREE. SIX FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE.
WEBSITE OR OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR STYLE
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME HE WILL BE A MUTED AND YOU
WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. DUE
TO SPACE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS A NEW
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES
WILL INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY EACH
SIDE WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME. AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU TODAY AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS. I WILL BE
MAINTAINING DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN THIS
HOUSE. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE BEATING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY HERE. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS. OR
TECHNOLOGIES. SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
WE MAY HEAR ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. WE HAVE SEVERAL BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA TWO MEASURES
ON OUR AGENDA WILL NOT BE
CONSIDERED THIS MORNING FILE
ITEM. NUMBER FOUR A. B. SEVEN
ONE ZERO AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX A. B. TWO TWO FIVE. WE HAVE
ONE MEASURE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN A.
B. ONE ZERO SEVEN TWO. WE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHEN WE'RE
ABLE TO DO SO IN THE INTERIM WE
WILL BE PROCEEDING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT IN
MIND LET'S MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AROUND EUROPE. WELCOME SIR YOU
HAVE ONE BUILDER PERCENT AS I
NOTED A. B. SIX NINE ZERO YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. AB SIX NINETY
WILL ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS. BY
CLARIFYING PRIVATE PRACTICE AND
OTHER PSYCHOTHERAPY SETTING
DEFINITIONS. FOR INDIVIDUALS
SEEKING LICENSURE AS A MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPIST A CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER OR A PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELOR FINDING
SUPERVISION IS OFTEN CITED AS A
BARRIER TO THEIR ABILITY TO
OBTAIN EMPLOYMENT AND GAIN THE
REQUIRED SUPERVISED HOURS OF
EXPERIENCE TOWARDS LICENSURE.
TO ENSURE SAFE AND ETHICAL
PRACTICE THE LAW PLACES
ADDITIONAL CONDITIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE OF
THREE LICENSED TRAINEES WHO ARE
STILL IN SCHOOL OR PRE LICENSED
ASSOCIATES GAMING SUPERVISED
EXPERIENCE HOURS AFTER
GRADUATION IN A PRIVATE
PRACTICE SETTINGS. HOWEVER THE
LAW FAILS TO PROVIDE A PRECISE
DEFINITION A BIT OF A PRIVATE
PRACTICE SETTING. AS MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT HAS BECOME
MORE ACCESSIBLE OVER TIME THE
VARIOUS TYPES OF SETTINGS WERE
PSYCHOTHERAPY IS PERFORMED HAVE
INCREASED LEADING TO CONFUSION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT CERTAIN
SETTINGS QUALIFY AS A PRIVATE
PRACTICE AND WHETHER OR NOT
SCHOOLS ARE PERMITTED TO PLACE
TREES THERE. EIGHTY SIX NINETY
PROVIDES THE NEEDED CLARITY
REGARDING PRIVATE PRACTICE
SETTINGS AND ENSURES THAT
PSYCHOTHERAPY ASSOCIATES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE FULLY UTILIZED
THUS HELPING TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA. I AM
JOINED TODAY BY WITNESS ROCK
SOUND HOMES LEGISLATIVE MANAGER
OF THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SERVICES. HIS. MISS HOLMES
PLEASE PROCEED HI I'M ROSANNE
HOMES LEGISLATIVE MANAGER FOR
THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND FOR TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AROUND TO LOOK FOR
AUTHORING THE BILL EIGHTY SIX
NINETY WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY REGARDING THE DISTINCT
TYPES OF PRACTICE SETTINGS
WHERE THE BOARD TRAINEES
ASSOCIATES AND LICENSEES WORK
HAVING SPENT. THE CIVIC
DEFINITIONS OF PRACTICE
SETTINGS WILL CLEAR EXISTING
CONFUSION ABOUT WHERE PRE
LICENSE TRAINING SO THE SOVIETS
MAY WORK THE BILL ALSO EASE THE
LIMITATIONS ON SUPERVISORS IN A
PRIVATE PRACTICE ALLOWING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE
SUPERVISORS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPERVISE AND PRIVATE PRACTICE
SETTINGS AS LONG AS THERE IS A
WRITTEN CONTRACT BETWEEN THE
SUPERVISOR AND EMPLOYER AND THE
EMPLOYER PERMITS THE SUPERVISOR
TO ACCESS THEIR ASSOCIATES
CLINICAL WORK RECORD. SO THAT
THEY CAN REVIEW THEIR WORK.
GATHER THE PURPOSE AMOUNT IN
BILL SHOULD MAKE GETTING SUPER.
OUR MORE ACCESSIBLE TO TRAINEES
AND ASSOCIATES. WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK OUR STAKEHOLDERS FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THIS
EFFORT AND THEIR ONGOING
CONTRIBUTIONS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS HOLMES LET'S MOVE TO ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHICH TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SIX NINE ZERO.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT AN INDIVIDUAL'S WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
SIX NINE ZERO WE WILL BEGIN.
AND IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY SIX NINE
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IT'S
ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY NONE. THANK
YOU MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
SEEING NONE CHECK ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO SEE IF THERE ANY
WITNESSES WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE AGAIN TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. SIX NINE ZERO. WE'LL PROCEED
WITH THEM. THANK YOU AND IF SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY
NONE. THANK YOU MODERATOR MOVED
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
CEREBRAL WE'RE NOT QUITE TO THE
POINT WHERE THE QUORUM BUT-
I'LL TAKE THAT MOTION AND NOTE
IT. SOME REMEMBER A REGULAR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I HAVE A TWIN IT IS
APPROPRIATE. AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY TAKE THAT VOTE AS
SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK
YOU SIR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE ARE WAITING FOR AN AUTHOR.
ANY OFFICER. COME ON DOWN.
C.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE WELCOME.
TO YOU OF ONE MEASURE UP TODAY
IT'S ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FOUR
ZERO SEVEN PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I- JUST DROP MY DAUGHTER
OFF AT CAMP THERE'S ONLY A TEN
MINUTE WINDOW NOW BECAUSE OF IT
SOME A LOT OF REST BUT WE'LL DO
THE BEST YOU CAN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN CENTERS AT FOURTEEN OH
SEVEN SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IS A MEASURE TO EDUCATE OUR
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE. ON THE
IMPACTS OF IMPLICIT BIAS IN OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. IN ORDER TO
BRING THE DISPARITIES AND
NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES IT CAN
RESULT INTO AND IT.
SPECIFICALLY AT FORTINO SEVEN
REQUIRES NURSING PROGRAMS. AND
HOSPITALS TO INCLUDE IMPLICIT
BIAS EDUCATION FOR NURSES.
EVIDENCE EXISTS THAT SUGGESTS
THAT PRINCE PRESENCE OF
IMPLICIT BIAS IN THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM LEADS TO
DIFFERENCES IN THE QUALITY OF
CARE GIVEN TO PATIENTS AS WELL
AS OVERALL HEALTH OUTCOMES. THE
SAME EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND WOMEN ARE THE ONES TO
BE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THIS
BIAS. IN A HEALTHCARE SETTING
DECISIONS AFFECTED BY THIS BIAS
CAN HAVE LIFE AND DEATH
IMPLICATIONS AS IT MANIFESTS
ITSELF THROUGH SUBTLE
DIFFERENCES IN HOW HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS INTERACT WITH
PATIENTS FOR DIFFERENCES IN
HEALTH CARE TREATMENTS. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND MUST BE
ADDRESSED EFFORTS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO REDUCE IMPLICIT BIAS IN
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND
THERE IS A- DEMONSTRATED
COMMITMENT BY THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND EDUCATORS TOWARD
MITIGATING NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES THESE EFFORTS MUST
CONTINUE IF WE ARE TO MAKE
STRIDES TOWARD ADDRESSING THE
HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR STATE MANY
DIVERSE POPULATIONS. AB FORTINO
SEVEN WILL BROADEN THESE
EFFORTS TO. BRING AWARENESS TO
THE ISSUES THESE ISSUES. I AM
MISSING IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING
FOR NURSES IN OUR STATE IS
ANOTHER STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TOWARD MEETING THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES. BUSINESS IMPACT OF
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
BOTH. IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
IS CHRIS LANG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION.
PLEASE PROCEED. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
LINE THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION PROBLEM SPONSORS OF
AB FOURTEEN OH SEVEN YOU THINK
THAT SIMPLY METAPHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN INTRODUCING THIS
BILL WHICH REQUIRES IMPACTED BY
EDUCATION FOR NURSING STUDENTS
AND YOU ARE IN LIFE AND GREEN.
NOT SURPRISING IMPLICIT BIAS
EXISTS AMONG PEOPLE ALL
PROFESSIONS HOWEVER WHEN YOU
PUT THE 5% IN THE HEALTHCARE
SETTING. IT MAY CONTRIBUTE TO
THE HEALTH CARE DISPARITIES
EXPERIENCED BY MEMBERS OF
RACIAL ETHNIC OR RELIGIOUS
MINORITIES AND OTHER GROUPS. I
WENT TO IMPLICIT BIAS IN A
HEALTHCARE SETTING IS
REFLECTIVE OF INADEQUACIES
WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
AND STRUCTURE. YOU OFTEN THE
THIRTY STILL TO LOOK AT THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. YOU
NEED NEEDS. A RESOURCES BUT-
PHILIP HE NEEDED TO TAP TO FILL
THOSE NEEDS. THEY DON'T EVEN
EDUCATORS MUSTDEMONSTRATE
THEIR COMMITMENT TO ENDING
RACIAL HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
WORKING FOR HEALTH EQUITY BY
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUING
STRATEGIES THAT ELIMINATE THE
BIAS WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. EIGHTY FORTINO SEVEN
RECOGNIZES THAT AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION IS THE FIRST STEP
TOWARD ELIMINATING IMPLICIT
BIAS IN A HEALTHCARE SETTING.
EDUCATING THE FUTURE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AND THEY ARE MINDFUL
ABOUT THE IMPACT ON THE DEVICE
TO THE PATIENTS THEY SERVE IS
PARAMOUNT. TO BRING IN THIS
PHENOMENON TO ENHANCE.
CERTAINLY WE'VE USED ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS ON TV ALSO. NOT
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR LINE LET'S TURN TO
THE GALLERY TO SEE IF THERE ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S TURN TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE TO CHECK TO SEE IF
THERE ANY WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THEY'RE-
SAYING NO WITNESSES THANK YOU
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY. VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROPERTY SUCH WITNESSES
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF A B. ONE FOUR ZERO. SEVEN WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND IT IS ONE AND THEN GENERAL.
ONE MOMENT HERE WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
NUMBER THIRTY ARMSTRONG ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOURTEEN ZERO
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINES
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN SPORTS. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. AND THEN FURTHER AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION BEGINNING WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE LET'S
CHECK ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF
THEIR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THERE I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
FEDERATED FEUD PLEASE PROMPT
ANY WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE A. B. ONE FOUR ZERO
SEVEN WILL PROCEED. AND PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY NONE THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. YOUR CONCERNS. MR
SINGH NONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. WITH
THAT- I THINK THE NEWMAN AND
YOU HAVE A QUESTION COMMENT OR
CONCERN I'D LIKE TO COMMENT SO
I SIMPLY WON'T WORK THANK YOU
FOR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL- THE PROBLEMS AROUND.
POSTED BY ACCIDENT ESPECIALLY
CLEAR DURING THE PANDEMIC GLAD
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY GLAD
TO MOVE IT WANTS PROBE. THIRTY
SEVEN AND THEN WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM I WILL ACCEPT THAT
MOTION AND WE WILL. PROCEED OF
ABSOLUTE CORN THOUGH. SOME OF
THEM THE BURKE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE WITH I RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS AND I BUT WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU
MA'AM BEING A JOB. I THINK. SO
REMEMBER TELL YOUR ONE BILL TO
PRESENT TODAY WELCOME SIMPLY
BILL SIX NINE ONE PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS EIGHTY SIX NINE ONE
WOULD ENSURE THAT OPTOMETRISTS
AUTHORIZED TO ADMINISTER CLI
ABLE CLEAR SLEEVE COVER
NINETEEN TEST AND COVER
NINETEEN VACCINES IN AN EFFORT
TO HELP IDENTIFY AND STOP THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AS OF JUNE
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THERE HAVE BEEN MORE THAN THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION CONFIRMED
CASES OF COVER NINETEEN IN
CALIFORNIA. RESULTING IN MORE
THAN SIXTY TWO SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND DEATHS THE QUICKEST
WAY TO GET OUR STATE BACK TO
NORMAL IS TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES TO THE POPULATION
CURRENT LAW AUTHORIZES
IMMUNIZATION CERTIFY OF TOM
TRYS TO ADMINISTER THREE
VACCINES FOR THOSE EIGHTEEN OR
OLDER WHICH INCLUDE INFLUENZA
HERPES ZOSTER VIRUS AND CAMEL
CARCASS CLINICAL LABORATORY
IMPROVEMENT AMENDMENTS OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ALL CLEAR
RECENTLY WAIVED POINT OF CARE
TESTS FOR COVER NINETEEN WHILE
COMMENTERS ARE AUTHORIZED TO
ADMINISTER CLEAR WEEK TELL US
THEY. ARE RESTRICTED TO
CONDITIONS OF THE I. EIGHTY SIX
NINE ONE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN
A NUMBER OF WAYS FIRST IT
AUTHORIZES OPTOMETRIST TO APPLY
TO THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY FOR AN IMMUNIZATION
CERTIFICATE. TO ADMINISTER A
STARTS COLD TO VACCINE SECOND
IT WOULD ESTABLISH THE
SUBSTANCE OF AN APPLICATION
FORM FOR THE IMMUNIZATION
CERTIFICATION AND EXPAND THE
CERTIFICATE TO COVER- THE
ADMINISTRATION OF IMMUNIZATION
FOR THE VIRUS. FINALLY IT ALSO
AUTHORIZES OPTOMETRISTS TO
PERFORM A CLEAR WAY FOR
CLINICAL LABORATORY TESTS
NECESSARY TO DETECT. THE
PRESENCE OF SUCH VIRUS FIVE
RACHEL BLEACHER ON BEHALF OF MY
SPONSOR THE CALIFORNIA UP TO
METRIC ASSOCIATION TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MS BUTCHER PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RACHEL BLEACHER WITH ME OFTEN
MARKED THEM ARE TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
OPTOMETRIC ASSOCIATION THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
TO A FAMILY MEMBER CHOPPER
INTRODUCING THE SPELL THAT
SPELL OUT EXPLICIT LANGUAGE THE
OPTOMETRY PRACTICE ACT TO
PREVENT OPTOMETRIST TO
ADMINISTER THE CULVERT NINETEEN
VACCINE. UNTIL THE NINETEEN
CLEO TESTS. UPCOMING TRIP-
TRAINED HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS HAVE ATTENDED
FOUR YEARS OF GRADUATE SCHOOL
TO OBTAIN A DOCTOR OF
OPTOMETRY. PLUS COMPLETED
EVEREST RESIDENCY TRAINING AND
PASS LICENSURE EXAMINATION.
WHEN A CONSUMER WE AUTHOR A
WAIVER THAT ALLOWS CERTIFIED
OPTOMETRISTS ADMINISTER THE
COVERT NINETEEN BACK THINGS.
THE PERSON SIXTEEN YEARS OF AGE
AND OLDER DURING THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD MAKE THE AUTHORIZATION
PERMANENT FURTHER UNDER CURRENT
LAW OPTOMETRIST MAN MINISTER
OTHER VACCINES. THAT PERFORM
CLEAR WAIT FOR CONDITIONS OF
THE I. EIGHTY SIX NINETY ONE IF
NECESSARY TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
UPCOMING TRIPS ARE ALSO ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE COVER NINETEEN
VACCINATION. AND CLEAR WAY PAST
IN AN EFFORT TO HELP IDENTIFY
AND STOP THE SPREAD OF THIS
VIRUS. ARE STRICTLY ADHERE I
VOTE AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S. TURN TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY. SEEING
NO. SUCH WITNESSES EXCUSE ME
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE A.
B. SIX NINE ONE. SEEING NONE
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SIX NINE ONE
WILL PROCEED. AND IF SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
CURRENTLY NONE THANK YOU. LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION FIRST
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S TURN TO ROUTE
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE. WHAT'S MOVED
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION BUT IT MUST BE
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. SIX NINE
ONE. WE WILL AGAIN PROCEED.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN IT IS. TWO
ONE ZERO. AND CURRENTLY NONE
THANK YOU LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS. SEEING
NONE SEMI MEMBERS SHALL WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET WE WILL
TAKE A VOTE IN A MOMENT BUT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU SENATORS. THANK YOU SIR.
CALYXT FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WERE NOT HERE AT THE TIME THAT
I MADE THE ANNOUNCEMENT. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. B. SEVEN ONE
ZERO. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
WILL NOT BE CONSIDERED THIS
MORNING AND ITEM NUMBER SIX A.
B. TWO TWO FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY. WILL NOT
BE CONSIDERED THIS MORNING.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AN AUTHOR ANY
OFFICER.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVIN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW. CALLING ALL ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
THAT IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVIN I CAN'T TELL WITH
MASKS YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FILE LATER IT'S
VIOLATED TEN ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
THREE ZERO I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY AUTHORIZES AN EXCAVATOR
FOR COVER ATTORNEY ATTORNEY
FEES TO DEFEND THEMSELVES FROM
LAWSUITS ARISING FROM POORLY
MARK AND SUBSEQUENTLY DAMAGED
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THE CPC INITIATED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY'S
LOCATE AND MARK PROGRAM. THE
CPC REPORT DETERMINED THAT PG&E
FALSIFIED UP TO ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN CLAIMS
FALSIFIED THEM THESE MARKINGS
ARE USED BY CONSTRUCTION CREWS
TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHERE.
THEIR DANGEROUS UNDERGROUND
PIPELINES ARE LOCATED THE CPC
ALSO REPORTED SIXTY SEVEN
INSTANCES OF DAMAGE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS A RESULT. OF
THE FALSIFIED RECORDS. THE C.
P. C. ALTERNATELY FIND P.
JEANNIE ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THESE
VIOLATIONS. THROUGH THE COURSE
OF THE C. P. C. INVESTIGATION
IT WAS A TERM THAT PG&E WOULD
LEVERAGE ITS LEGAL RESOURCES TO
FILE CLAIMS AGAINST. LESS
RESOURCEFUL EXCAVATION
CONTRACTORS PEOPLE THAT WE
NORMALLY CALL SMALL BUSINESSES.
THE INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT
PG&E CREATED A WAR ROOM WITH
THE SOLE INTENTION TO MAXIMIZE
THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS AGAINST
CONTRACTORS. EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
WILL MAKE UTILITY COMPANIES
THINK TWICE BEFORE FIRING OFF
CLAIMS IT WILL FORCE THEM TO
INCREASE THE ACCURACY OF THEIR
UNDERGROUND INFRASTRUCTURE AT
LOCATING PROGRAM. INCREASING
SAFETY FOR WORKERS AND THE
PUBLIC THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU MR CHER AND- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THIS IS GERALD
MELZER IS SPELLED M. O. USY I.
S. BEEN A PRACTICING ATTORNEY
IN CALIFORNIA FOR APPROXIMATELY
FORTY ONE YEARS AND THEN THE
MANAGING PARTNER OF THE MOUSE'S
LAW FIRM IN TUSTIN SPECIALIZING
IN CONSTRUCTION LAW ON
CONSTRUCTION RELATED CLAIMS I
AM ALSO A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. ATTORNEY'S FEES
ISSUES ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT IN
CALIFORNIA WE USE THE AMERICAN
ROLE WHICH IS BASICALLY THAT
ALL PARTIES PAY THEIR OWN WAY.
EXCEPT FOR TWO MAJOR EXCEPTIONS
ONE BY CONTRACT IF THERE'S A
CONTRACTUAL CLAUSE AND OTHERS
BY STATUTE. HERE IN THE
SITUATION OF EXCAVATORS
DEPENDING THESE LAWSUITS THERE
IS NO CONTRACT THEREFORE
THERE'S NO CLAIM FOR ATTORNEY'S
FEES THAT WOULD GO EITHER WAY
THERE. SO THIS STATUTE IS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE
ESCALATORS FROM THESE NUISANCE
VALUE LOSSES. IS CONSISTENT
WITH OTHER STATUTES THE
CALIFORNIA FALSE CLAIMS ACT
UNDER THE GOVERNMENT CODE HAD A
ONE WAY ATTORNEYS FEES CLAUSE
IN FAVOR OF THE- PROSECUTING
AUTHORITY IN THOSE MATTERS THAT
IF THERE WAS A FALSE CLAIM
RECUT RECOVERY COULD BE MADE
AGAINST A CONTRACTOR WHO
SUBMITTED A FALSE CLAIM OR
REQUEST FOR PAYMENT. THAT WAS
NOT TRUE- THAT WAS LATER
AMENDED IT BUT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS- WHERE A
CONTRACTOR CAN GET ATTORNEYS
FEES THEY ASKED TO SHOW A
FRIVOLOUS NATURE UNLIKE THE
PROSECUTING AUTHORITY PROMPT
PAYMENT STATUTE CALL FOR
ATTORNEYS FEES- GOING WHERE
THERE'S NO GOOD FAITH DISPUTE.
THERE WERE PAYMENT WITHOUT. AND
EVEN IN- THE SPECIAL MOTIONS TO
STRIKE THE ANTI SLAPP STATUTES.
DOES CALL FOR DIFFERENT
STANDARD OF ATTORNEYS FEES
GOING EITHER WAY DEPENDING ON-
WHETHER OR NOT THE PUBLICATION
WAS CONSIDERED TO BE IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST OR NOT SO. ALL
OF THESE STATUTES WHETHER ONE
WAY OR TWO WAY BY WAY OF
PREVAILING PARTIES- WILL FORCE
POTENTIAL LITIGANTS AND
ATTORNEYS TO EVALUATE THEIR
CLAIMS EARLY ON. A RATHER THAN-
AS ASSEMBLY PERSON LEVINS AND
JUST LAUNCH OFF INTO LITIGATION
OR WITH CLIENTS- THEY TO DERIVE
NUISANCE VALUE LOSSES. THIS
BILL WILL PROMOTE SAFETY WHERE
WILL FORCE THE HIGHER UPS AT
THESE UTILITIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE LINES ARE MARKED
PROPERLY. AND IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH THE POLICY- UNDERLYING
OTHER STATUTES ENACTED. TO
MINIMIZE LITIGATION- BY
AVOIDING THESE NUISANCE VALUE
LOSSES- AGAINST EXCAVATORS WHO
ARE THEN FORCED FOR ECONOMIC
REASONS. WE PAY THE SETTLEMENT
RATHER THAN DEFEND THEM ON THE
MERITS SO THANK YOU MR HERE FOR
YOUR TIME AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE A NIGHT FULL ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS SOME OF MY NOTES
INDICATE MISTER STEVE WARD.
GOOD MORNING COMMUNITY AND
SHARE HER APPRECIATE YOUR
HEARING MY TESTIMONY. WIND
SPEED AND MORE- OKAY LET ME
CHECK IN SYSTEMS. WE GET
ANOTHER DESTRUCTION. VANDERBILT
NO PARTY I CAN GIVE. NINE
SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY. IT IS PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH CLAIMS-GUARDED
INTELLIGENCE- BEFORE I CAN GET
MY COUNTRY TO PAY HER CYCLE
SINCE. SMALL CONTRACTOR IF YOU
CAN PULL YOU. IN AUGUST I WOULD
LEARN SOMETHING GRANITE
CONSTRUCTION. ON OUR STATE
HIGHWAY IN TWENTY NINE PALMS.
THE COMPLETED. CONSTRUCTION THE
CRIME ON THE PROJECT- LET ME
KNOW THAT THERE IS A HUGE
DECLINE FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. AND THEN ON
A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
DAMAGE TO. SEVERAL OF THEIR
BALLS. FOR PICTURES LIKE THE
PICTURE TO RESOLVE THERE WE NOW
HOLD COMPLAINING HAD NOT DONE
THE DAMAGE IS MORE LIKELY TO
BACK ON OKAY WE TO BRING. THE
BALL- ARE YOU ON JULY I'M LIKE
A PROVE IT. OWNED BY THE
EXPERIENCE WITH EACH. SO ALMOST
DONE THE DEFENSE. THE GENERAL
THE FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
CLIMBED. NON WE CAN. MIGHT
GRANDMA CASE I THOUGHT YOU
REALIZE THEIR NOT CALL FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR YOU MEAN A FINE
THOUSAND KICKS. ON MANAGEMENT
TEAMS ACROSS. THE BUSINESS
DECISION I WOULD JUST PAY THEM
BECAUSE. OF THIS FUNCTION FOR
THEM. IT'S BEEN. NEARLY YOU
WERE NOT TO CALL IN YEAH. OUR
YOU LOOKING AT MY SPRING W.
AFFECTING BUT DID YOU YEAH ALL
OF THEM. DID YOU KNOW THIS. WE
SHOULD BE TWENTY BILLION. RMB
EVEN OLD ENOUGH THEY'RE NOT
WITH FOR THEM THE NUMBER. WORK
YOUR ONE- THE COST. IN. NOT THE
MOVE LIKE THE ONE EACH OUR ON
THE LINE OF DURING CLASS ON ONE
THANK YOU FOR CALLING ARE YOUR
YOUR YES WELCOME TO H. THANK
YOU SIR LET NOW MOVE TO THE
GALA TO CHECK ANY WITNESS AND
SOME. I SEE ONE WITH SIR PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK MR CHAIR MEMBERS
BLUM STYLE FOR THE SO CAL. CON
SO. IN SUPPORT OF A NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LET'S TURN TO
THIS IS. ROOM ONE TWO AND SOME
OF. A BEING THREES. I SEE NO
WHAT DOES LET'S MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO. IF ANY V.
TELECONFERENCE. BUT- IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
WITNESSES WAITING TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE THREE ZERO
WE WILL PROCEED. THANK YOU AND
IF SO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. IN A
MOMENT HERE. M. S. ONE ZERO CAN
YOU BUY AND ONE JUST GIVE ME
ONE. IN LINE AT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU SKIP DOMON B.
AFTER THE AMERICAN
SUBCONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA HUNDREDS OF- MERIT
SHOPPING UNION COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. NINE THIRTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE CAROLINE. ARE CURRENTLY
NINE OTHERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION CHECKING WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NONE WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WHICH
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THREE ZERO I
SEE NONE LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. WE
WILL PROCEED. AND TAKING IT
AGAIN IT IS ONE ZERO. FOUR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO. CURRENTLY NONE.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS I SEE SENATOR JONES
PLEASE PROCEED. MR CHAIRMAN-
SOMEONE RELIVING THAT I
TYPICALLY HAVE A CONCERN WITH
ONE SIDED- LEGAL FEE RECOVERY-
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE IS WELL
REASONED. CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO
THAT- AND YOU KNOW WHY NOT. YOU
KNOW MAKE IT EQUITABLE. YEAH SO
I THINK I EQUITY AS A REALLY
FASCINATING TERM TO USE LET'S
LET'S WALK THROUGH KIND OF WHAT
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO HELP
HERE SO YOU'VE GOT A SMALL
BUSINESS CONTRACTOR. THEY
FOLLOW THE LAW THEY CALL EIGHT
ONE ONE. THEY HAVE THE LINES
THE GAS LINES MARKED. BAY THEN
FOLLOW THAT. LISTEN TO IT IT
HERE TO IT DO EVERYTHING
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO AND THEN
IN WHEREVER IT IS THAT THEY'RE
DOING THEIR WORK NOT THE MARK
LINES END UP HITTING A LINE- SO
WHAT YOU SAW IN THE P. U. C.
INVESTIGATION WAS THAT. P.
GENIE IN PARTICULAR ACTUALLY
HAD AN ORGANISM ORGANIZED-
OPERATION. TO MAXIMIZE CLAIMS-
OUT OF THESE TYPES OF ISSUES
WHERE THEY HAD MISSED MARKED
LINES. AND THEN THEY TRIED TO
SAY TO THE EXCAVATOR. IF YOU
GIVE US TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
WE'LL JUST SETTLE THIS. BUT YOU
KNOW YOU'VE GOT A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT A SMALL
BUSINESS YOU KNOW CONTRACTOR IN
IN THE COMMUNITY SAYING WELL IF
I NEED TO HIRE AN ATTORNEY FOR
THIS. IT'S GOING TO COST ME
FORTY GRAND. SO IT'S CHEAPER
JUST TO PAY OUT. TO THE MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR COMPANY WHOSE
PUT. MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
RESOURCES TO MAXIMIZING THESE
EXACT SAME TYPES OF
SETTLEMENTS. THEY THEY THEY
DON'T HAVE A WAY TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES FROM ALL OF THAT. SO
IT'S INTERESTING TO TALK ABOUT
EQUITY WHEN YOU'RE TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO WERE YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT. DONE YOU KNOW
MONTHLY YOU KNOW HOW ARE WE
GONNA PAY THE BILLS AND PAY OUR
EMPLOYEES VERSUS A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR. CORPORATION SO
IN IN THIS. SITUATION WHERE THE
CONTRACTOR CALLS EIGHT ONE ONE.
THAT'S THE END OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY AS FAR AS WHERE
THE MARKINGS ARE PUT AND- AND
ALL THAT THAT'S DONE EITHER BY
THE- THE UTILITY OR- A
CONTRACTOR THAT THE UTILITY.
HIRES TO COME MAKE THOSE
MARKINGS AND EXCAVATORS JUST
FOLLOWING. WHAT THEY'RE BEING
TOLD TO FOLLOW BY THE UTILITY
IS THAT CORRECT. YOU KNOW I I'D
BE GLAD FOR ONE OF THE
WITNESSES WHO YOU KNOW WORKS
DIRECTLY WITH CONTRACTORS ON
WHAT THE SPECIFICS ARE. I GUESS
THAT MIGHT THE BOTTOM LINE OF
MY QUESTION IS. ON THE
EXCAVATING AND WHERE TO
EXCAVATE WHERE DOES. THE
EXCAVATORS RESPONSIBILITY END
AS FAR AS- WHERE THEY PUT THEIR
SHOVEL I GUESS IT IS THE- MOST
DIRECT WAY CAST THAT QUESTION.
IF WE NEED TO GO ALONG ON THE
LINE LET'S HOLD THAT THOUGHT.
LET'S TAKE IT WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BECAUSE I
HAVE MEMBERS BOUNCING AROUND
FROM COMMITTEE TO COMMITTEE AND
I CURRENTLY HAVE IT ON THE
FLOOR SO. CENTER JONES IF YOU
WILL ALLOW ME TO ABSOLUTELY I
WISH A CORN BEFORE YOU GET AN
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION. HOLD
THAT QUESTION. THESE ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. ROTH HERE ROSS HERE
MELENDEZ ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
HERE BEATS BEATS HERE BACKER
DODD ADMIN I MEAN HERE HER TADO
JONES HERE JONES HERE AT LLEVA.
MAN MAIN HERE NEWMAN NEW MEN
HERE AND SHOW ABOUT OKAY. CAN
HE CAN HEAR. DAUGHTER HERE.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM CENTER
PAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HELPING SENATOR DODD CENTER
ADMIN CENTER JONES BACK TO YOU
IN YOUR QUESTION THANK YOU SIR
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY- YOU
KNOW IF WE'RE GONNA IF WE'RE
GONNA PROVE IN A ONE SIDED
LEGAL COST RECOVERY I JUST WANT
TO KNOW WHERE THE PERSON
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE- LEGAL FEES.
RESPONSIBILITY BEGINS AND
EXCAVATORS RESPONSIBILITY ENDS
IF WE COULD JUST HAVE SOME
CLARIFICATION. ON THAT PLEASE.
SIR YEAH AS I MENTIONED I WOULD
PREFER TO DEFER TO A WITNESS
WHO DOES THAT EXCAVATION WORK
OKAY WE NEED A LIFELINE HERE
YES SIR. EUROPE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SNATOR- CENTER JONES TODD
BLOOM SIGN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE EXCAVATOR
TO DIG BETWEEN THE LINES THAT
ARE MARKED- TO ENSURE THAT
NOTHING IS STRUCK- CONTRACTORS
WILL ALSO GO TO A HIGHER LEVEL
OF DILIGENCE. AND POTHOLE AT TO
IDENTIFY WHERE THOSE
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES ARE
THAT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE EXCAVATOR WANTS THE DICK
SERVICES COME OUT AND MARKED
THE LINES. THANK YOU SIR CENTER
JONES. COLLEAGUES ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
I SEE NONE SEVEN MEMBER LEVIN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH I
THINK YOU SO MUCH RESEARCHER
THANK YOU ALSO FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL QUESTION AND- IN
THE DELIBERATION OF THE
COMMITTEE WE ALL OPPOSE
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS AND THIS IS
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO AND WE DON'T WANT
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES TO BE
PREYED. UPON TO BE PREYED UPON
BY MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
CORPORATIONS HERE AND- AND THIS
BILL- SETTLES AT ISSUE I
RESPECT THE HOUSE FOR A VOTE.
Q. NEXT UP ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS
BUILD CENTER NEWMAN MOVES THE
BILL. THE MOTION IS DUE PROCESS
AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMISSION COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM TEN EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY DO YOU PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
ROTH R. ROSS I MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D BEAT.
BEATS BY BECKER'S DAUGHTER HI
DAUGHTER HI AIKMAN HI ADMIN I.
HER TADO JONES. JONES II LEYVA
MEN. MAIN I NEWMAN NEWMAN I
SHOW A BOGUS HAND. BILL HAS
EIGHT VOTES OFFICIALLY GET OUT
BUT WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RESEARCHER THANK YOU MEMBERS.
LET'S RETURN TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN. WELCOME YOU HAVE ONE
BUILDER PRESENT TODAY A. B.
FOUR SIX EIGHT PLEASE PROCEED
IN READING GOOD MORNING MR
TERENCE SENATORS I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS
I'M MAKING A COMMITMENT TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS IN SENATE JUDICIARY
TO ADDRESS THE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS. IN THE
ANALYSIS. AMBER THIS IS A BILL
THAT IS A CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURE. TO PROTECT SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND I'M JUST GONNA
TAKE A SECOND TO TELL YOU THE
INSPIRATION FOR THIS BILL. IT
CAME AFTER I HEARD A STORY ON
NPR. ABOUT A FAMILY WHO HAD A
SEVERELY AUTISTIC CHILD. WHO
THEY WANTED TO PURCHASE A
SUPPORT ANIMAL. TWO OF. THE
THOUGHT TO HELP CALM THE CHILD
SO THEY PAID I BELIEVE IT WAS
AROUND TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
A DEALER WHO CLAIMED THAT THESE
WERE SPECIALLY TRAINED SUPPORT
ANIMALS. TOOK THE DOG HOME. THE
DOG IMMEDIATELY ATTACKED THE
FAMILY'S OTHER PET. KILLED IT
IN FRONT OF THIS CHILD CAUSING
DEEP TRAUMA TO THE CHILD WELL
IT TURNS OUT THAT UNDER THE
LAW. THERE IS NO DEFINITION OF
AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT ANIMAL
THERE IS NO TRAINING THAT IS
REQUIRED BY LAW. THIS WAS A
FRAUDULENT SALE. TO A VERY
VULNERABLE MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY. NOW THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO PROTECT THOSE THE
RIGHT TO PEOPLE WHO
CONSISTENTLY HAVE TO FIGHT FOR
EQUAL ACCESS TO PUBLIC SPACES
AND BASIC CIVIL RIGHTS. TO
SAFETY AND INDEPENDENCE RATES
AVAILABLE FREELY TO THOSE
WITHOUT DISABILITIES. EIGHTY
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT WOULD PREVENT
THE SALE OF EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
ANIMALS AND THEIR EQUIPMENT. AS
BEING REPRESENTATIVE OF HAVING
THE SAME RATES AS A GUIDE
SIGNAL OR SERVICE DOG. AND IT
REQUIRES A SILVER MOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMALS AND EQUIPMENT.
TO BE ACCOMPANIED WITH A
WRITTEN NOTICE EXPLAINING TO
CONSUMERS BUT THEY DID NOT
CONFIRM THE SAME TRAINING. THE
SAME FOR THE SAME BENEFITS AS
AS GUIDE DOGS AND SERVICE DOGS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT A
HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONER.
PROVIDING DOCUMENTATION
RELATING TO AN INDIVIDUAL'S
NEED FOR AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
DOG. THAT IS NOT A GUIDE OR
SERVICE DOG AS DEFINED. AND
LESS THE HEALTHCARE
PRACTITIONER COMPLIES WITH
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS. IT IS A
PRIVILEGE NOT A RIGHT TO BE THE
OWNER OF AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
OR SERVICE DOG. AND THE TWO
CLASSIFICATIONS DO NOT MERIT
THE SAME LEVEL OF PUBLIC
ACCESS. UNFORTUNATELY
INDIVIDUALS HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITY ACT FOR THEIR OWN
PRIVILEGE ACCESS IN PUBLIC
SPACES. BUT CONSEQUENTLY PUT
EVERYONE AROUND THEM AT RISK OF
HARM BUT USUALLY THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY NEED A GUIDE OR A
SERVICE DOG. PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO USE TASKTRAINED SERVICE DOGS EARNED
THEIR RIGHT TO BE IN PUBLIC
SPACES AS A RESULT OF RIGOROUS
TRAINING OF A RIGOROUS TRAINING
PROCESS. AND ENSURING THAT
THEIR SERVICE DOGS SATISFIED
BEHAVIORAL STANDARDS UNDER THE
ADA. THE FRAUDULENT AND CRUEL
SELLING OF EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
DOGS AND IDENTIFYING EQUIPMENT
IS ENTITLING THE SAME ACCESS
RATES AS SERVICE DOGS. NOT ONLY
CREATES CONFUSION TO THE OWNER
OF THE ANIMAL. BUT ALSO TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC WHICH HAS TO
COMPLY WITH ADA LAWS.
ADDITIONALLY THE PERCEIVED NEED
FOR THIS IDENTIFYING EQUIPMENT
DUE TO BUSINESSES STRESS TO
FIND THIS REQUIREMENT. IS
BASICALLY TO FRAUD IT'S
BASICALLY DEFRAUDING PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DISABILITIES. EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTY WILL HELP CURTAIL THE
MISREPRESENTATION OF BUYING AND
SELLING EMOTIONAL SUPPORT DOGS.
AND THEY'RE IDENTIFYING
EQUIPMENT AS HAVING EQUAL
ACCESS RATES AS TRAINED SERVICE
DOGS. CREATING A SAFER PUBLIC
SPACE FOR ALL ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES WHO RELY ON
THESE TASKS TRAINED DOGS FOR
THEIR INDEPENDENCE. THIS BILL
IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN THE ASSEMBLY- INVISIBLY B.
APPEARED ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
WITH NO NO VOTES. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MORNING IS
RABBIT DOWN FROM GUIDE DOGS FOR
THE BLIND. I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL CONSDERATION OF
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED WITH THIS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN I THINK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN. HELLO
MY NAME IS RUBY A DULL I AM
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF GUIDE
DOGS FOR THE BLIND. THIS
MORNING. IN SUPPORT OF. FOUR
SIX EIGHT- I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
SUMMARIZED IT VERY WELL. TO US
L. LOCATED BETWEEN. TO PROTECT
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. AND ON
A SERVICE ANIMALS NOT JUST FOR
INDEPENDENCE BUT FOR THE
QUALITY OF LIFE. FOR US AS
ANIMAL SERVICE ANIMAL HANDLERS
AND FOR OUR FAMILIES AS WELL.
WE RELY ON OUR SERVICE ANIMALS
TO CONDUCT OUR DAILY. JENNIFER
LIKES BUSINESSES FROM GOING TO
SCHOOL GOING TO WORK. FAMILY
TAKING A CASE TO THE DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENT. THIS IS A
NECESSITY FOR MANY OF US. AND
SERVICE ANIMALS HAVE BEEN
CONFISCATED FOR DECADES AS A
LEGITIMATE AID. BEEN WELL
INTEGRATED INTO OUR SOCIETY.
UNFORTUNATELY RECENTLY OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS AS A FAMILY
MEMBER FINANCIAL STATED WE'VE
HAD THIS GROWTH OF. REALLY
PREDATORY BUSINESSES ONLINE
THOMASINE THAT THEY CAN TAKE ME
BACK AND GIVE THEM A
CERTIFICATE OF THE DATE PRINT
OUT OF THE COMPUTER. IN FACT
BASICALLY THAT SIGNIFICANT
WOULD GIVE THEM. EQUAL ACCESS
TO PUBLIC SPACES A SERVICE
ANIMAL. IT PUTTING THAT BACK IN
DANGER OF PUTTING MANY OTHER
PEOPLE AROUND THAT. DOG HANDLER
OR ANIMAL HANDLER IN DANGER AS
WELL. TURNING SEVEN A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. ON THOSE OF
US WHO DO DEPEND ON OUR SERVICE
ANIMAL. I JUST WANT A QUOTE-
SOME NUMBERS FROM MANY-
SURVEYED THAT OUR SISTER
ORGANIZATION OF COSPONSORED-
CANINE COMPANIONS FOR
INDEPENDENCE CONDUCTED LAST
YEAR. 93% OF THOSE WHO
RESPONDED TO THE SURVEY THESE
ARE THE JUDGMENTS OF HER CAMEL.
LOWS 93% REPORTED. THAT DOES
COME IN CONTACT WITH. A
QUESTIONABLE HOOKS SPEAK
SERVICE ANIMAL OR THE FAKE
SERVICE ANIMALS IF YOU WILL.
LOG IN A BOX. 78% OF THOSE
COMMANDERS REPORTED THAT THEIR
OWN DOG WHAT A TRACK. BY THE
SCHOOL BETWEEN. EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMALS OR MAYBE
ILLEGITIMATE SERVICE ANIMALS IF
YOU WILL- 64% OF. THE GERMAN
SERVICE ANIMAL HANDLERS.
REPORTER BACK TO BE QUESTIONED
ABOUT THEIR OWN SERVICE ANIMAL
AND WHETHER THEY ARE LEGITIMATE
SERVICE ANIMALS AND THE PURPOSE
OF ANIMAL. THANKS FOR
SUBSCRIBING AS A RESULT OF ALL
THAT. YET OVER TWO THIRDS. OF
SERVICE ANIMAL HANDLERS.
REPORTED A NEGATIVE IMPACT. NOT
JUST ON THEIR OWN INDEPENDENCE
AND QUALITY OF LIFE BUT THAT OF
THEIR FAMILIES. AND IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S A GROWING
PROBLEM THAT- WE DO NEED SOME
HELP WITH. TO CONTROL FOR
EVERYBODY'S SAKE AND
EVERYBODY'S SAFETY. WE
APPRECIATE THE HEARING THIS
MORNING. AND ESPECIALLY ASKING
FOR MY VOTE. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY MEDICAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR LET'S
TURN TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AND SUPPORT. SEE NO
SUCH WITNESSES WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIX EIGHT. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES. WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIX
EIGHT. WE WILL PROCEED. THANK
YOU AND AGAIN IT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO PERSONAL LINE OF. NUMBER
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR STERN THIS IS MATT
ROBINSON WAS SHOT YOU'RE INTO
CMOS RELYING ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. LINE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY THANK
YOU AFTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MARGIE DONOVAN I'M A
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA ARE THE
NATIVE OF CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
WORKED SAYING I DON'T YOU'RE
FORTY YEARS. HI I AM SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF THIS SONG. SORRY
IF THIS BILL. AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY TO INCIDENCES OF MANY
THAT I'VE ENCOUNTERED I HAD A
DOG JUMPED OUT OF THE CARTON
COLD FROM THE TRACK MY STOCK IN
STORE PERSONNEL DO NOTHING
MA'AM I'D HAVE. TO TALK TO
ANIMALS. I'M SORRY AT THIS
POINT- THIS PORTION OF THE
PROCEEDING WE ASK WITNESSES TO
SIMPLY STATE TEIR AFFILIATION.
YOUR RELATIONSHIP THE BILL AND
YOUR POSITION SO I GATHER
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. HELLO I AM INDEED IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE AND I'M
A MEMBER OF GUIDE DOG. GOLDEN
STATE GUARD DOG HANDLERS AND
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
ASSISTANCE DOG PARTNERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APOLOGIZE FOR OUR TIME
CONSTRAINTS. NEXT PLEASE OKAY.
LINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THIS IS
KEITH DONE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION I'M
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS MAYBE
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT AND LIKE TO
THINK THAT SOMEONE IN THE
FAMILY MEMBER FOR ENERGY SINGLE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE. NINE FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH I THINK CAN
YOU HEAR ME PERFECTLY PLEASE
PROCEED. I'M IN FAVOR OF THIS
MY NAME IS SHERRY HAPPY I AM A
DOG GUIDE OWNER SINCE ABOUT
NINETEEN SEVENTY. CURRENTLY
AFFILIATED WITH. ORGANIZATIONS
I'M A CONSUMER WOULD BLIND WITH
A DOG GUIDE. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT PLEASE. NINE NINE FURTHER
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION FIRST OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. I SEE
NO WITNESSES IDENTIFYING
THEMSELVES LET'S TURN TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE TO CHECK TO SEE IF
THERE ANY WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THERE. I
SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE A.
B. FOUR SIX EIGHT. WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
MUCH AGAIN IT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE ON
YOUR KEYPAD. CURRENTLY NONE.
EXCUSE ME. WE ARE CURRENTLY NOT
IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR LET'S
TURN TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THE CHAMBER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
AND CONCERNS CENTER JONES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THIS TO ME
SOME WOMAN FRIEDMAN THIS IS A
GREAT BILL- RIGHT YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT I THINK HIT ALL THE
RIGHT MARKS ON THIS- I THINK
THEY'LL PROBABLY BE AS A RESULT
OF THIS YOU KNOW DISH NETWORK
WE NEED TO DO IN THIS ROUND YOU
KNOW MOVING FORWARD YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE SOLVING A BUNCH
OF PROBLEMS BUT- I IMAGINE
THERE'S- LOTS OF- UNFORESEEN-
YOU DON'T CHALLENGES COME UP AS
WELL BUT I I'M ALL IN FAVOR OF
THIS MY MOTHER IN LAW. IS A
BREEDS AND TRAINS- SUPPORT
ANIMALS- SHE DOESN'T MOURN A
HOBBY LEVEL AND- AND JUST TO
THE AMOUNT OF TRAINING. THAT
GOES INTO THESE ANIMALS ONE ON
ONE. AT  LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T I
DON'T THINK GRASP THAT YOU KNOW
I HOURS DAYS WEEKS MONTHS. AND
SO- TO GET TO AN ANIMAL TO THE
POINT WHERE THEIR- CAPABLE AND
TRAINED AND ABLE AND- IT THIS
IS GREAT SO I SUPPORTED- HAPPY
TO MAKE THE MOTION FOR APPROVAL
AND WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED ON
AS A CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS CINNAMON IF DESIRED
THANK YOU RICHARD LET ME ADD
ONTO CENTER CHALLENGES
COMMENTED I DO APPRECIATE THIS
BILL. A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THE
KIND OF LEGISLATION THAT TURNS
OUT YOU MAY NOT HAVE THOUGHT
ABOUT IT. BUT IT IS CLEARLY
NEEDED- AND CLEARLY WILL BE
BENEFICIAL I WOULD ALSO ASK TO
BE. ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF
THAT'S POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
PERFECT CETERA I'D LIKE TO ALSO
THANK THE AUTHOR OF WHEN WE
THINK OF THE PEOPLE
DISABILITIES THAT NEED THESE
DOGS- IT IS VITAL VICTOR NOT
ONLY WELL PROTECTED BUT WELL
REPRESENTED IN THE IN THE
PURCHASE OF THE DOGS AND I'M
THINKING OF THE VETERANS WHO
ARE NOW BECOMING MORE MORE
ACTIVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES WITH
PTSD AND THE DOGS ARE MAKING A
WORLD OF DIFFERENCE AND SHOW
WHEN YOU GET A GOOD QUALIFIED
CERTIFIED ANIMAL THIS IS
FANTASTIC AND I TOO WOULD LIKE
TO BE PART OF THE- THIS
MOVEMENT. TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WE HAVE TO PROTECT THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES AND I'D BE HONORED
TO BE A CO AUTHORS WELL THANK
YOU SENATOR HATCH LISTENER BASE
ON THANK YOU. TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'M JUST
GOING TO JUMP ON BOARD AT ALL
IT'S A GREAT DEAL- HAVE A-
COUPLE OF PERSONAL STORIES THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO SHARE A
BED TIME IT'S A LONG OVERDUE SO
THANK YOU MATCH AND I WOULD
LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR. THANK
YOU MA'AM CENTER ADMIN. I THINK
YOU AND ALSO JUST TO. ADD ON TO
SAY. I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT SPACE AND I THINK.
THE WHOLE IDEA OF EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT DOGS HAS BECOME JUST
BLOWN OUT AND- AND VERY ABUSED.
BY AND SO. I THINK ANOTHER
COMPONENT THAT WILL HAVE TO
WORK ON GOING FORWARD AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THEIR SPACE IN
HERE BUT TO JUST DO A REAL. A
PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGN.
ABOUT WHAT THE DIFFERENCES ARE
BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW. AND THAT'S PART OF
THE PROBLEM. GOING FORWARD AND
I THINK ALSO THAN BEING ABLE TO
REGULATE. AT WHERE THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO GO. OR NOT TO GO- IS
ALSO AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT
THAT WILL NEED TO WORK ON GOING
FORWARD. THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR EDWIN COLLEAGUES ANY
OTHER. COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. SEEING NONE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- JUST TO SAY
THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT AND I. FEEL VERY
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO CARRY
THIS. BILL AND I. TO SENATOR
EGGMAN'S POINT. I THINK BESIDES
THE GENERAL PUBLIC WHO THINKS
THAT IF THEY PURCHASE A VEST ON
LINE IT MEANS ALL OF A SUDDEN
THAT THEY HAVE A DOG THAT CAN
GO ANYWHERE. OUR BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE AFRAID. TO REGULATE-
THEIR OWN BUSINESSES AND THESE
ANIMALS DO PUT ACTUAL GUIDE
DOGS AND SERVICE DOGS OFTEN IN
DANGER. AND THE PUBLIC AS WELL
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE SUPPORT
HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR JONES THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. NUMBERS I'D LIKE TO
REMIND YOU TO PLEASE HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE ON. FILE ITEM FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIX EIGHT DO
YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. ROSS
HI. ROSS HI MELINDA'S.
ARCHULETA ALL RIGHT. BURCHILL
OUT I'D BEATS HI. BEATS I
BACKER. BACKER DIED. DODD I
HATE MEN HI HEY MAN I TALK JOE
THANK. HI JOAN I LLEVA. MAN I
MEAN I KNEW MAN HI NEWMAN I A
SHOW ABOUT OKAY HAND. BILL HAS
NINE VOTES SUFFICIENT TO GET
OUT WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NICE JOB
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDING SIR THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE PLEASED TO HAVE YOU
HERE YOU HAVE THREE ITEMS THE
FIRST ONE IS A B. TWO TWO NINE
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU GERMAN ROCK AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TODAY I
PRESENT AN ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
TWO NINE THE BILL THAT
PROHIBITS A PERSON REQUIRED TO
BE REGISTERED AS A SECURITY
GUARD FROM CARRYING OR USING A
FIRE ARM OR BATON A LESSON
SECURITY GUARD IS AN EMPLOYEE.
OF A PRIVATE PATROL OPERATOR
LICENSEE OR AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
STATE. MEMBERS OF THE CAT
COUNTRY WATCHED THE TRIAL OF
THEIR CHILDREN THE EX POLICE
OFFICER CHARGED WITH THE
KILLING OF GEORGE FLOOR THERE
WAS A SIMULTANEOUS DISCUSSION.
REGARDING LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE TRAINING OF THE APPROPRIATE
USE OF FORCE. THE CONVICTION OF
CHILDREN WITH THE FIRST STEP IN
SECURING JUSTICE FOR FOUR. NOW
THE NATION SETS ITS SIGHTS ON
THE OTHER THREE OFFICERS THAT
FAILED TO INTERVENE AND
ULTIMATELY WATCHED AS FLOYD'S
FINAL MOMENTS ON EARTH EXPIRED.
BUT TODAY I WANTED TO KNOWLEDGE
AND BRING AWARENESS TO THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE OTHER MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY CARRY FIREARMS
BATONS. LLOYD TO KEEP OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND PROPERTY SAFE
AS WELL AS THE FINANCIAL
DEALINGS OF BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THEY ARE
HARD TO KEEP THE PEACE AT
SPORTING EVENTS AND CONCERTS.
THERE ARE SECURITY GUARDS. BUT
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS DIFFER
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AND A
NUMBER OF AREAS I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THEY OFTEN FACE SIMILAR
SITUATIONS EVEN TRAGIC ONES.
MEMBERS MARIO MATTHEWS WAS A
MEXICAN AMERICAN WHO WORKED AS
A WAREHOUSE WORKER. ACCORDING
TO A LAWSUIT FILED BY HIS
PARENTS ON JULY SECOND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AT AROUND
THREE THIRTY AM AFTER ATTENDING
AN OUTDOOR CONCERT FOLLOWING
TWO NBA EXHIBITION GAME
TOMORROW ENTERED THE GOLDEN ONE
CENTER. HERE IN SACRAMENTO
THROUGH A PROPPED OPEN DOOR
WHICH WAS PART OF THE MAIN
ENTRANCE. VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
SHOWED MARIO RUNNING AROUND THE
COURT AND DRIBBLING AS IF HE
WAS PLAYING BASKETBALL. BEEN TO
UNIVERSAL PROTECTION SECURITY
PERSONNEL BEGAN CHASING MARIO
AND EVENTUALLY DETAINED HIM.
THE LAWSUIT ALLEGES THAT MARIO
WAS SLAMMED FACE FIRST INTO A
WALL. TACKLED AND RESTRAINED
FACE DOWN ON THE FLOOR HIS
HANDS WERE HANDCUFFED BEHIND
HIS BACK IN THE TWO SECURITY
PERSONNEL GOT ON TOP OF HIS
BACK. ONE SECURITY GUARD USES
RIGHT NEED TO APPLY PRESSURE TO
THE SIDE TOMORROW SNACK FOR
APPROXIMATELY FOUR AND A HALF
MINUTES. IN ADDITION TO THE
INITIAL TWO UNIVERSAL
PROTECTION SECURITY PERSONNEL A
THIRD SECURITY OFFICER PLACED
HIMSELF ON MORROW'S BACK.
MORROW BECAME UNRESPONSIVE AND
WAS TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL HE
PASSED AWAY TWO DAYS LATER. THE
LAWSUIT CLAIMS AT THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY CORONER
ACKNOWLEDGE THE RESTRAINT WAS A
CAUSE OF MORROW'S DEATH.
ADDITIONALLY THE CORONER'S
PATHOLOGIST REPORT NOTED DEEP
BRUISING ON MARS BACK AS A
RESULT OF THE WEIGHT AND
PRESSURE THAT HAD BEEN PLACED
ON HIM. MARIO WEIGHED A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE POUNDS. WELL
THE NATION DEBATES LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S TRAINING ON THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS
CURRENTLY HAVE NO TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR COURSES ON THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE.
EIGHTY TWO TWENTY NINE WOULD
AD THE APPROPRIATE USE OF
FORCE TO THE TRAINING COURSES
WITHIN THE PRIVATE SECURITY
SERVICE ACT INCLUDING TRAINING
ON THE USE OF OBJECTIVELY
REASONABLE FORCE. THE
ESCALATION TECHNIQUES IMPLICIT
AND EXPLICIT BIAS AND CULTURAL
TRAINING. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE COURSE
AND THE CARRYING AND USE OF
FIREARMS TO INCLUDE TRAINING IN
THE APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATION COULD HELP SAVE
OTHERS. MEMBERS MY OFFICE HAS
BEEN AND HAS HAD TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH AND REVIEW THE
LETTER. OF CONCERN FROM CONSECO.
WE HAVE SPENT THE PAST FEW DAYS
WORKING TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO THE REQUIREMENT THAT
THE USE OF FORCE TRAINING BE
CONDUCTED IN A TRADITIONAL
CLASSROOM SETTING. I'VE
COMMITTED TO CALL CIGNA THAT I
WILL WORK WITH THEM TO FIND AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN.
TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM TRAINING
AND THEIR SUGGESTION OF WEB
BASED. PLATFORM TRAINING. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND THE CONSULTANT FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE ON THIS BILL. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
IS STUART KATZ ATTORNEY FOR THE
FAMILY OF MORROW MATTHEWS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MISS
CATS PLEASE PROCEED. A GOOD
MORNING I THINK THIS
LEGISLATION IS APPROPRIATE AND
OVERDUE. I BELIEVE THAT MOST
PEOPLE DO BOTH HIRE SECURITY
GUARDS. IN GOOD FAITH AND
INTERACT WITH IT WILL BE
SHOCKED TO FIND OUT THEY
RECEIVED NO TRAINING. IN THE
REGIONAL USE OF FORCE. THIS
BILL IS NOT TURNING SMALL NOT
OF INTO BUT IN POINT OF FACT I
BELIEVE THERE ARE MORE.
REGARDING INDIVIDUAL COMING
THIS. THEN ARE FOUR LAW.
OFFICERS HELLO. THE FOLKS FOR
INTERACT THE PUBLIC. YOU KNOW
FAR RIGHT FOR. THE BEST OF THE-
ONLY CALL ONE FOR AFTER THEY'VE
ALREADY KIND. WITH ARE CLEAR NO
DOWN IN THIS BILL AND GIVEN THE
LIMITED TRAINING THEY RECEIVE
AT THIS POINT. THE INCREMENTAL
DIFFERENCE. IN THIS TRAINING
FOR FORCE- WON'T HAVE MORE OF
IF YOU'LL BANG FOR BUCK FOR THE
PEOPLE GIVING THE TRAINING AND
JUST ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE IN
TERMS OF RESISTANCE- PRODUCING
UNNECESSARY. INJURIES DO ALL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TYPE CONTACTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR WHEN I
TURNED A WITNESS IS IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. AB TWO TWO NINE SEEING
NONE LET'S TURN TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. CHECK TO SEE IF THERE
ANY WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY THEY'RE SEEING NONE
LET'S TURN TO THE
TELECONFERENCING. MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. TWO TWO NINE
WE WILL PROCEED. SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY NONE THANK YOU LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS WITH
REGARD TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION BEGINNING WITH THE
GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IDENTIFYING THEMSELVES LET'S
CHECK ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF
THERE ANY WITNESSES WAITING
THERE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO TWO NINE I SEE NO
SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD THANK THANK
YOU AND PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IT WAS JUST A
MOMENT HERE.
AND WE DO HAVE TO
ISSUE HERE PLEASE- BEAR WITH ME
HERE. PLEASE PROCEED. AND FIRST
OF ALL THE LINE UP TWENTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF MY NAME'S JERRY DESMOND WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSED INVESTIGATORS WE'RE
NOT OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE AT
THIS TIME WE'VE JUST RECENTLY
IDENTIFIED THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL THAT WOULD AMEND THE
PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR ACT TO
REQUIRE USE OF FORCE BY A
LICENSED PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR
AND- FOLLOWING ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH WE'VE IDENTIFIED A
CONFIRM THAT. THAT PROVISION
THAT'S AN EXISTING- PETE I ACT.
SHOULD NOT BE THERE IT WAS A
CARRY OVER FROM WHEN THE P. I
ACTED THE SECURITY ACT WORK I
CAN GET IT BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE I BELIEVE THAT.
THAT'S REFLECTED IN THE BILL
ANALYSIS WE'RE SUGGESTING THAT
THE MEASURE BE AMENDED TO
ELIMINATE THE CURRENT- BNP CODE
SECTION SEVEN FIVE FOUR TWO
SUBDIVISION. A ONE BECAUSE A
PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR DOES NOT
HAVE THE POWER OR THE AUTHORITY
TO ARREST PARTY ARREST ONE OF
THE READY TO USE FORCE. IN AND
WE BELIEVE IT'S A US A
CARBOCATION AMENDMENT THAT
WE'VE JUST BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION THAT THE AUTHOR AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE AS IT WAS
FOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. YEAH AND OVER ON
CLIMATE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DAVID CHANDLER I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF CAL SAGA- THE
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSE SECURITY AGENCIES GUARD
SHORT. WE ARE ALL OPPOSE TO
BILL- WE JUST HAVE SOME- WE
HAVE THE TO WORK WITH- SOMEONE
THEM AND THEY SHALL. ON THIS
WE'D GO WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IT- OUR BIGGEST ISSUE. FOR THE-
INSTRUCTOR TO BE PHYSICALLY. IN
THE ROOM AS WELL KNOW GOING.
ALL THAT- CLASS SHOULD. WERE
WERE STOPPED AND WE DON'T WANT
TO. THIS SITUATION HAPPEN AGAIN
AND WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
EMPLOY PEOPLE- AT THAT POINT
BECAUSE YOU WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO HAVE A CLASSROOM SESSION SO-
MR HOLDEN'S OFFICE BUT AS SHE
WAS GRACIOUSLY WORKING. WITH
US- YOU ALSO PLEASE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. THAT OUR EMPLOYEES ARE
AT MINIMUM WAGE OR JUST ABOVE
MINIMUM WAGE AND IT IS
SOMETIMES HARD FOR THEM. TO GET
TO FROM A- A PERSONALITY IN
ORDER TO- TAKE THE INITIAL
POWERS OF ARREST CLASS AND
WHICH WOULD ADD THE- ESCALATION
DISTORTION PORTION OF THE
PROPRIOCEPTION CLASS IN THAT
PORTION IN ORDER TO BE A SECURE
YOU ARE. IN CALIFORNIA- SHOAL
DAILY. IT WOULDN'T JUST BE
TOUGH FOR THEM ALSO- IN THE-
SECOND SECTION OF- THIRD
SECTION ON PAGE NINE OF YOUR
BRIEF- THE BUREAU OF FOREIGN.
MISSILE LAUNCHERS TRYING TO
HELP. WITH REMOVING THE WORD
PHYSICAL ALTERCATION FOR
REPORTING. MECHANISMS FOR THE
GIRLS WHO INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES ON ANY PHYSICAL
ALTERCATION REMOVING THE WORK
PHYSICAL. ANY ALTERCATION THERE
ARE FOUR WOULD BE RECORDABLE
THE BERYL WITH THINGS THAT
WOULD BE. A TREMENDOUS BURDEN.
DAILY IN HIGH- SITUATION-
SECURITY. ARE CALLED TO US
HOSPITAL PER. IN RESTRAINING
PEOPLE. THAT ARE MENTALLY ILL
PRESIDENT. BUSH AND THAT WOULD
BE A TREMENDOUS REPORTING
ISSUES. WITH THEM AND WE DON'T.
WE JUST WON'T CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE SEMINOLES OFFICE AND
THEN YOU JUST CLARIFY THIS THE
SMALL LITTLE POINTS. MHM THANKS
SIR. NEXT THANK YOU. NO FURTHER
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS
COLLEAGUES FIRST CINNAMON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT
TO- FIRST COMMAND THE AUTHOR-
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT WAS WAS
VERY POWERFUL AND THIS IS
CLEARLY A PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED AND- I APPRECIATE-
THE THOUGHTFULNESS BEHIND THIS
BILL IT SEEMS TO STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE IN IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE- REAL CONCERN THAT
WE ALL READ ABOUT- IT
UNFORTUNATELY ALL TOO COMMON
THESE DAYS- AND SO I. WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL I DID HAVE
ONE QUESTION AND THAT IS THAT
GIVEN THE COURTS AND I SAY
COURTS IN THE PLURAL BUT THE
SUPREME COURT AND ALSO MADE A
FEDERAL COURT'S. VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN IN MY VIEW
EXCESSIVE EXCESSIVELY EXPANSIVE
VIEW OF THE SECOND AMENDMENT- I
DIDN'T SEE THIS IN THE COMMUNAL
SISTER HERE FROM ANY OF THE
WITNESSES BUT- PERHAPS YOU
COULD ADDRESS SOME OF THE ART
DO YOU THINK THEIR SECOND
AMENDMENT CONCERNS.
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE
PROVISION THAT WOULD- PROHIBIT
REGISTERED SECURITY GUARDS FROM
CARRYING OR USING FIREARMS.
UNLESS THEY ARE AN EMPLOYEE OF
A PPO LICENSEE OR THE STATE OR
POLITICAL SUBDIVISION IS STATE.
I GUESS MY CAN MINOR CONCERN
MIGHT BE THAT THAT WOULD RUN
INTO- JUDGES JUST LIKE THE ONE
WE SAW IN SAN DIEGO THAT TAKE
THAT. EXPANSIVE VIEW THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND MORE THE WELL
REGULATED ART- AND THEN WE
COULD SEE SOME PROBLEMS WITH
THAT SO I JUST OPEN IT UP FOR
YOUR RESPONSE- THANK YOU
SENATOR I THINK YOU PROBABLY
TEED UP AN IMPORTANT- QUESTION
TO BE ADDRESSED IN OUR NEXT
COMMITTEE THAT THE BILL WOULD
BE- PRESENTED AND- OUR- OUR
GOAL CERTAINLY IS NOT TO TRY TO
RUN AFOUL. OF FEDERAL LAW- WE
WANT TO RAISE UP A STANDARD IN
WHICH THESE PRIVATE SECURITY
GUARDS. ARE TRAINED ESPECIALLY
IN THE USE OF EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE. BECAUSE WE BELIEVETHAT
IN TERMS OF THE LEASE CAROLINE-
ALLOWING THAT TO HOW- LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS SWORN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA UNDER POST.
ARE TRAINED- WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO TURN THEM INTO THAT BUT JUST
ALSO TO GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT
MORE ROBUST. INTRODUCTION TO
HOW TO ENGAGE IN ENGAGE WITH
THE PUBLIC. AND IN MATTERS OF
ADDRESSING- THE USE OF FORCE
WITHIN THE CONTEXT. AS CONSIGO
REPRESENTATIVE. IDENTIFIED THE
STATUES THAT THE GOVERNOR- SO
WE- I CAN JUST SAY THAT. AS WE
MOVE TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE. I'M
SURE THAT- AS IT RELATES TO
SORTOF THE- THE LEGAL JUDICIAL
TYPE OF ISSUES THAT. YOU'VE
RAISED WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GET OUR ARMS AROUND THOSE AS
WELL BUT- WE CERTAINLY. ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO COLLABORATE. CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE WITH
ADMINISTRATION- WE HAVE- BEEN
WORKING SIDE BY SIDE WITH THEM
TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE WERE
GETTING THE RIGHT FEEDBACK- SO
THE RECONSTRUCTION THE BILL
ACCORDINGLY. AND THAT WITH THE
INDUSTRY ISSUE FOR TODAY WE'VE
BEEN. AND DEEP- PARTNERSHIP.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT IT
WILL WORK WITH THE JUDICIAL
COMMITTEE. AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
TO ADDRESS ANY ISSUES THAT
ALONG THE LINES THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSE AND I APPRECIATE THAT-
IT'S A RIGHTEOUS BILL AND IF I
COULD I WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR AT THE EARLIEST
APPROPRIATE TIME. TO BE MINOR.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU SENATOR
BENTSEN AND PLEASE AND THANK
YOU MR ENDED IN MISTRIAL THANK
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL GLAD TO
SUPPORT TODAY. I WANT TO. VISIT
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT MR
CHANDLER FROM CAL SAGA. BROUGHT
UP AT THE THERE'S A NUMBER OF
INSTANCES- REFERENCED IN THE
ANALYSIS WERE EITHER LANGUAGE
USE AMBIGUOUS OR THERE'S A NEED
FOR. ADDITIONAL DEFINITION-
PAGES NINE AND TEN AND SO I
GUESS THE EASIEST WAY TO DO
THIS IS. I'M I'M I'M ASSUMING.
YOU'RE AMENABLE TO MAKING THESE
AMENDMENTS. YES AND I WOULD I
GUESS I WOULD ASK ARE THERE
ANY. INSTANCES IN THE ANALYSIS
WHERE YOU WOULD TAKE ISSUE.
WITH THE PROPOSED MINUTES AGO
THEY ALL SEEM VERY REASONABLE
TO ME. I KNOW I THINK THAT THEY
ARE VERY REASONABLE I THINK WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT-
YOU KNOW AS WE'RE SORT OF BEING
INTRODUCED TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS. HERE AT THIS AT THIS
JUNCTURE IN THE IN THE- COURSE
OF THIS BILL. THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SORT OF SIT DOWN
AND UNDERSAND SORT OF. ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT DYNAMICS BUT IT
SEEMS VERY. STRAIGHTFORWARD WE
CERTAINLY DON'T SEE ANYTHING
THAT WOULD JUMP OUT AT US AS-
BEING OFFENSIVE AND WILL- I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU WILL PROBABLY GET
TO A SOLUTION AND- THIS WILL
PROBABLY BE THE KIND OF
LANGUAGE THAT WILL. COME UP
WITH WHAT WE JUST. DISCOVER
SOME LATITUDE TO SORT OF.
BETTER UNDERSTAND AND SERVE FOR
FINESSE THE DETAIL OF THE
LANGUAGE BUT THERE. THE THEME
IN CONTEXT OF WHAT IT'S HOW
IT'S PRESENTED WE WOULD
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THAT YEAH I
TRIED I DO APPRECIATE THAT SO-
YOU KNOW IN. IN MANY CASES
ANALYSIS YOU REACH. A GOOD
POINT WERE CLEARLY THERE ARE
CERTAIN ISSUES TO BE THE
PRINCIPAL OR OR POLICY-
ABETTING THIS CASE IT'S REALLY
JUST ABOUT. YOU KNOW FINDING
THE APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE- THAT
EITHER DOESN'T LEAVE SOMETHING
UNDEFINED. OR OR IT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING- CLEAR AND WITHOUT
AMBIGUITIES ARE PREACHING YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO DO THAT THANK
YOU THAT IS WHAT THE BILL
TODAY. THAT SPOT ON THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU CENTERMAN.
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS CONCERNS
CENTER ADMIN. THANK YOU MR
CHECK. NICE TO SEE YOU ASSEMBLY.
I ONE SO I GUESS ADJUSTED TO-
FOLLOW UP FROM CENTER NEWMAN'S.
I UNDERSTAND YOU MEAN YOU'RE
MAKING A COMMITMENT TO US BUT
IF YOU'RE GONNA LOOK AT THIS
LANGUAGE AND IF IT IS STILL
AMBIGUOUS AND THERE'S- HOLES OR
WHAT. BUT YOU WILL BE MOVING
FORWARD WITHOUT. WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS TO BE ABLE TO-
ADDRESSED THE TECHNICAL CHANGES
AND AMBIGUITY IN SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE. YEAH I THINK WHAT TO
THANK YOU FOR. GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR
I THINK WHAT. HAS BEEN RAISED
ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WAS
SORT OF OUTSIDE THE CONTOUR HOW
WE'VE BEEN MOVING FORWARD. AND
SO WE'RE JUST SORT OF BECOMING
ENGAGED ON THIS- I DON'T SEE
ANY REAL ISSUES. AND IT'S
PROBABLY JUST WORD SMITHING I
THINK THE COMMITTEE. WAS
TAKING. THE HIGHLIGHTING
ELEMENTS THAT WERE IN THE
LETTER PRESENTED BY BECAUSE I
GOT IT AND WE JUST WANNA. MAKE
SURE THAT IN ADDRESSING THEIR
ISSUES WE DON'T. INADVERTENTLY
DO ANYTHING THAT UNDERMINES THE
SPIRIT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH SO MUCH. I MAY BE
BEING- A MORE CAUTIOUS BUT I'M
NOT. I'M SAYING THAT I'M
AGREEING WITH THE COMMITTEE'S.
DIRECTION AND WHAT- BOTH-
MEMBERS OF THE HIGHLIGHTED AND
WE WILL. GET TO- AGREEMENT. ON
ON ON ON THE LANGUAGE IN THE
SPIRIT AND INTENT. OF WHAT IT'S
DESIGNED TO ACCOMPLISH OKAY
THANK YOU. YEAH I DON'T THINK
ANYONE SO YOU HAVE TO ACCEPT
EXACTLY WHAT'S WRITTEN HERE BUT
AS YOU'RE MOVING FORWARD TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE. THAT PEOPLE
FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT THERE'S
NO AMBIGUITY WE'LL BE ABLE TO
BE IMPLEMENTED CORRECT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I SHOULD NOTE
THAT SPANISH TENNIS BILLS
DOUBLE REFERRED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY SO. THIS COMMITTEE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE NEXT
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BILL IS JUST RIGHT COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS FURTHER WHEN
SURVEYS. ACTUALLY I JUST WANT
TO THANK ABOUT A FAMILY MEMBER
PULLED IN FOR US IT'S VERY
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO THIS
OFTEN WE HAVE- LEFT HANDED THIS
IS SUPPORT- WITH AMENDMENTS AND
I THINK I'D LIKE TO COMPLIMENT
TELL SEGA FOR APPROACHING IT
THAT WAY BECAUSE WE'VE HAD A
VERY GOOD DISCUSSION HERE FROM
THE AUTHOR ON HOW HE WILL
APPROACH- THERE WERE THERE
ISSUES AND- THEY WILL THEN BE I
THINK A BETTER BILL AND NOT
SOMETHING THAT WILL GET
WIDESPREAD IF NOT UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT SO I STRONGLY SUPPORTED
AND I THINK IT'S THE DIRECTION
THAT WE NEED TO GO ON WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PROFESSION. THAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
MANNER IN WHICH YOU APPROACHED
OUT PHIL WANTED TO GIVE YOU A
HIGH FIVE ON THAT THANK YOU AND
I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL. TO
PROTECT THE SEVEN MEMBER
HOLDING WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON A. B. TWO
TWO NINE. CENTER JOEL. WE THE
BILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FOR FILE ITEM SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO TO NINETY PASSING
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY ROSS ROSSI
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
EYED PEAS BEETS I BACKER.
BACKER I'D DIED DOT I A MAN A
GOOD MAN I HER TADO JONES.
LLEVA MAN. MAN I KNEW MAN.
NEWMAN I WOULD SHOW A BOGUS HAN.
BILL. BILL IS A VOTE SO IT'S
ENOUGH TO GET OUT THE WHOLE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SIR. CERTAIN EXCITED
THANK YOU FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FOUR
EIGHT YOU MAY PROCEED SIR.
THANK YOU GERMAN- AND MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FOUR EIGHT THE BILL
THAT REQUIRES THAT EVERY
CONTACT OR CONTRACT FOR THE
SALE OF REAL PROPERTY CONTAIN A
NOTICE INFORMING THE BUYER AND
SELLER OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPORT ANY SUSPICION OF
DISCRIMINATORY. APPRAISAL BY A
REAL ESTATE APPRAISER THROUGH
THE BUREAU OF REAL ESTATE
APPRAISERS AND TAT INTERNET. A
WEBSITE OR TELEPHONE NUMBER.
FOR THOSE WHO SEEK TO REFINANCE
THEIR PROPERTY THE NOTICE WILL
BE PROVIDED IN THE LOAN
MATERIALS. AMID THE FAIR
HOUSING ACT IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT PROHIBITS HOME APPRAISERS
FROM DISCRIMINATING BASED ON
RACE RELIGION NATIONAL ORIGIN
OR GENDER. HOWEVER OVER FIFTY
YEARS AFTER THE ACT WAS PUT IN
PLACE THE HOMES OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE STILL BEING
UNDERVALUED. RECENTLY THERE
HAVE BEEN A SERIES OF
DOCUMENTED INSTANCES WHERE THE
HOMES OF PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
BEING UNDERESTIMATED. FOR
EXAMPLE IN MARIN CITY AN
APPRAISER UNDERESTIMATED A
BLACK COUPLES HOME BY NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN OAKLAND AN APPRAISER LOWBALL
THE VALUE OF A BLACK AND PORTER
RICAN COUPLE'S HOME BY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND.
THERE HAVE BEEN ADDITIONAL
HEADLINES AND NEWS REPORTS OF
RACIAL BIAS IN REAL ESTATE
APPRAISALS THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. EIGHTY NINE
FORTY EIGHT WILL REQUIRE THE
GIRL REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS TO
PLACE ON ITS EXISTING COMPLAINT
FORM A PLACE FOR BUYERS AND
SELLERS FOR WITH PERMISSION THE
REAL ESTATE REPRESENTATIVES TO
VOLUNTARILY. PROVIDE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION. EIGHTY
NINE FORTY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE
THE BUREAU TO COMPILE THE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION AND
SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON OR BEFORE JULY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. IN
TERMS OF CONTINUING EDUCATION
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE AN
APPLICANT TO FOR PRAISE A
LICENSING TO COMPLETE. CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AND ELIMINATION OF
BIAS TRAINING. FINALLY THIS
BILL HAS ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE TO
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
ACT REGARDING DISCRIMINATION IN
THE PROVISION OF APPRAISAL
SERVICES. MEMBERS FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE HOME IS
CONSIDERED TO BE THEIR GREATEST
ASSET. THE EQUITY IN THEIR
HOMES ALLOWS THEM TO FIND
CONTINUING EDUCATION FOR THEIR
CHILDREN'S RETIREMENT AND
HEALTH EXPENSES FINALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR IN THE
CONSULTANT FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL AS WELL AS THE
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF.
EQUALIZATION FURTHER UNANIMOUS
ENDORSEMENT OF THIS BILL I
BELIEVE THIS IS A TIMELY BILL
AND I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THOSE OTHER THAN JUST COMPLETE
THOSE WHO WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. R. AND A
BOOK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. AND
MIKE BELOW WITH THE APPRAISAL
INSTITUTE. MS BUCK YOU MAY
PROCEED. HI GOOD MORNING CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PERFECTLY
PLEASE PROCEED. EXCELLENT GOOD
MORNING MR KARAT NUMBERS IN THE
BOTTOM HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE ARE
A DIVERSE ORGANIZATION OF OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND REALTORS
WHO UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WE ARE
EXTREMELY PLEASED WITH THE PORT
EIGHTY NINE FOUR EIGHT I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
TIRELESS WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. AMONG OTHER PROVISIONS
EIGHTY NINE FOUR EIGHT WILL
REQUIRE ANTI BIAS TRAINING FOR
REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS I
REQUIRE THAT EVERYBODY LOOKS
REAL PROPERTY PURCHASE
AGREEMENT CONTAINS A NOTICE
STATING THAT THE BUYER AND
SELLER ARE ENTITLED TO AN
UNBIASED APPRAISAL THANK YOU.
CONTACT INFORMATION. AFTER THE
PARTY. IT ALSO INJURED THAT AND
IT WILL PUT IT IN LINE WITH
SHOULD THE CONSUMER B. INVOLVE
IN EVERY. OF THE PROPERTY
REQUIRED AN APPRAISER. IF YOU.
COSTS THE DID HE VALUATION OF
PROPERTY EITHER FROM BIAS OR
FROM SOME OTHER MEANS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE VALUE PROPERTY IS
AN OBSTACLE TO BUILDING EQUITY
WHICH WORKS TO PERPETUATE
INCOME. INEQUALITY IN OUR STATE
REDUCED PROPERTY VALUES ALSO
DESTABILIZE COMMUNITIES. AND
REDUCING EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES. THAT
ARE SO VITAL. OVER THE PAST
YEAR ALONE THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL HEADLINE MAKING STORY
THE COAL MINERS. BEING LOW
BALLED BY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS. DURING THE
APPRAISAL PROCESS. THE
SPECIALLY TRUE IN PREDOMINANTLY
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS. WHAT A
LEGACY OF REDLINING CAN STILL
BE FOUND. EIGHTY NINE FOUR
EIGHT CERTAINLY DOESN'T
ACCOMPLISH A GARGANTUAN TASK. A
LIMITING BIAS IN THE APPRAISAL
INDUSTRY. BUT THROUGH A SERIES
OF THOUGHTFUL PROVISIONS.
INCLUDE EXISTING LAW AND WILL
WORK TO MAKE BOTH HOME BUYERS
AND SELLERS. MORE AWARE OF
THEIR RIGHT TO CONDUCT AN
UNFAIR APPRAISAL. AGAIN WE ARE
SO PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND. ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR.
YES THANK YOU MR MY BELOW ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL GOV RELATIONS
COMMITTEE OF THE APPRAISAL
INSTITUTE THE NATION'S LARGEST
ASSOCIATION FOR REAL ESTATE
APPRAISING WE WERE PLEASED THAT
MR HOLDER REACHED OUT TO US
WHEN THESE REPORTS BEGAN TO
EMERGE AND HIS ABOUT REGIONAL
AND SIDED WITH WHAT IS REALLY A
GROWING NATIONAL DISCUSSION OF
IMPLICIT BIAS OR EXPLICIT BIAS
IN REAL ESTATE APPRAISING- AS
WE LOOK AT THE STORIES- THERE-
YOU KNOW WE CANNOT DENY THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THIS PROBLEM.
EXISTS IN OUR HEARTS WE LIKE TO
THINK IT'S SOMETHING OTHER THAN
BIAS BUT IN OUR HEADS WE KNOW
IT COULD WELL BE TRUE AND SO IT
IS PART OF A NATIONAL
DISCUSSION MR HOLDEN HAS-
ASSEMBLED A SUITE OF RESPONSES
TO THE PROBLEM WHICH WE THINK
ARE RESPONSIBLE IT'S FAR MORE
THAN JUST CONTINUING EDUCATION
IT IS THAT DISCLOSURE- DATA
GATHERING- A CLEAR STATEMENT IN
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
LAWS THAT- THE USE. OF I TAKE
CARE. INVOLVING REAL ESTATE IS.
UNACCEPTABLE THERE YOU KNOW AN
APPRAISAL IS A SNAPSHOT OF THE
AL YOU IN TIME. AND THE
PERSON'S RACE OR NATIONALITY OR
ETHNICITY OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH IT AND
SO WE'RE WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. PARENTHETICALLY I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE BILL WITH. AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN LAWYER AND
VERY PRESTIGIOUS POSITION IN A
IN AN INTERNATIONAL COMPANY.
AND SHE SAID YEAH AND IT'S
HAPPENED TO ME- SO THIS IS NOT
ISOLATED- IT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AND WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU IR
NOW LET'S HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IDENTIFYING THEMSELVES. WE'LL
CHECK ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF
THEIR WITNESSES THERE WAS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
NINE FOUR EIGHT. SEEING NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FOUR
EIGHT WILL PROCEED. THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
IS SO. WE'LL PERSONAL OF NINETY
NINE. SHARE AND SENATORS KEVIN
GOLD WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THE
BABY NINE FOUR EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOUR NEXT PLEASE. ONE
MOMENT HERE. ONE MORE WITH AN
OPERATOR JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
UHHUH. LINE ONE HUNDRED
CAROLINA'S OPEN. HI MISTER
CHAIR INCLUDING MEMBERS MY NAME
IS PAT YEAH I'M THE ONE I'M
WITH KATIE PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND
I'M CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION TO SUPPORT D. B.
NINE FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. AND CURRENTLY NOT NONE
FURTHER THANK YOU MODERATOR
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
WITH REGARD TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION BEGINNING WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
THE ENDING IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF MAYBE NINE FOUR
EIGHT. I SEE NO WITNESSES THERE
TURNING TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT. ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
WILL MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU
AND PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
THROW IT SO. CURRENTLY NONE IN
Q. THANK YOU LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS STARTING WITH
SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU ALL AND-
OKAY- WE NEED YOUR MIKE ON.
THANK YOU SENATOR HOLDING I I'D
THE SEMINAR HOLD AND- JUST-
APPRECIATE THIS BILL I THINK
YOU YOU MADE THE CASE IN. L. A.
HE NOTED THAT HOMES ARE FOR
MOST FAMILIES BY FAR THE MOST
VALUABLE ASSET WE HAVE AND
APPRAISAL THAT DUE TO IMPLICIT
RACIAL IMPLICIT OR EXPLICIT
RACIAL BIAS THAT DEVALUES THAT
ASSET IS OF TREMENDOUS CONCERN
PARTICULARLY AS WE AT THE STATE
LEVEL. CONTINUE TO LOOK TO WAYS
TO TRY TO BUILD WEALTH IN
HISTORICALLY UNDER SERVED IN-
pBILL IN AND AGAIN WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED. AS A CO AUTHOR AT THE
EARLIEST FOR EVERY MOMENT.
THANK YOU SIR CENTER CHULA
THANK YOU MR- SENATOR I AM SO
PROUD OF WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
TODAY THE FACT IS THAT WE'RE
EQUALIZING THE PLAYING FIELD
GIVING BOTH BUYER AND SELLER
JOB OPPORTUNITY PARTICIPATE IN
THE GROWING ECONOMY IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE HOMEOWNERS
TO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN THAT THAT
HOME FOR SELLERS TO GORDON TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE EQUITY THAT
THEY BUILT OVER A LIFETIME. AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PROPERTY
ITSELF IS VIEWED APPRAISED- OF
EQUAL TO OR GREATER THAN IN
SOME CASES BUT DEFINITELY EQUAL
TO THE SITUATION OF THE
AMENITIES THAT HAS IN THE
AMENITIES NOT THE OWNER SO WITH
THAT I'D BE HONORED TO BE A- A
CO AUTHOR AND I CERTAINLY WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL OF US
THAT WE'RE GOING FORWARD
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S- TALKING
ABOUT. EQUALITY ACROSS THE
BOARD IN THE REAL ESTATE
INDUSTRY AND- I URGE AND I
BUILT THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA SAID ARREGUIN
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR. MISTER ALL THE NIGHT I
RECENTLY. THERE IS A- AN
ARTICLE ABOUT MY FORMER MAYOR
WHO JUST RECENTLY HAPPENED TO
THAT AND THE CITY OF STOCKTON
EVERYONE KNOWS SHOULD BE BACK
IN THE DAY THERE WAS A CERTAIN
LINE THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR COULD
NOT LIVE ABOVE COULD NOT TRAVEL
ABOVE- AND MAYOR MICHAEL TUBBS
WAS RAISED IN THE SOUTH SIDE
AND HAVE MOVED INTO- THE
EUROPEAN NEIGHBORHOOD AND NOW
IS THERE A IS MOVING ON- IN HIS
HOME WAS I THINK I GET IT LESS
THAN. BEFORE ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS THA
SOMEBODY ELSE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD- CABIN IS ON THE
WAY HOME. AT THE END AND THEY
WERE JUST THEY WERE SHOCKED AND
THEN IT IT IT PREVENTED THEM
FROM BEING ABLE TO BUY THE HOME
THAT THEY WANT TO BUY. AS FOR
THEIR NEXT PLACE BECAUSE IT
WAS. BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FOR THE DOWN PAYMENT
THEM BECAUSE THEY WERE. SO
UNDERVALUED AND THEN THE BUYER
THEN COULDN'T GET A LOAN- THAT
MET THAT APPRAISAL IT WAS A BIT
WITH THE ASKING PRICE WAS TOO
HIGH SO. AS I WAS READING OVER
THAT I THOUGHT WELL. THAT IS
INTERESTING AND WOULD HAVE GOT
A GREAT. BILL IDEA AND SO. I
WAS. PLEASED TO SEE THAT YOU
ARE ALREADY WORKING ON IT AND I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS I THINK THIS IS
JUST ANOTHER FORM OF. BEST
PRACTICES ANOTHER FORMER
REDLINING. IF WE UNDERVALUE
WHAT SOMEBODY'S EARNED IN THEIR
EQUITY THAN THAT ALSO LIMITS OF
WHERE THEIR NEXT HOUSE CAN BE-
AND SO ON AND SO ON SO THIS. IS
AN ISSUE THAT CAN CONTINUE TO.
PASS DOWN TO THE GENERATION
pAREA KNOWS UNDER RUBIO'S ALSO
WORKED IN THE SPACE- SO ANYWAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO JOIN ITS CORE
THROUGH THIS. THANK YOU SENATOR.
CENTER JONES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND- SUMMER HOLDEN. I
AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT ON THE
CHALLENGES AND- YOU KNOW WHAT
MY COLLEAGUES SHARED. I AM A
DCA. LICENSEE MYSELF AND- I
JUST SPEAKING PERSONALLY
BECOME. FRUSTRATED WITH THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION- SYSTEM
AND- YOU KNOW WE HAVE- FIRST OF
ALL I JUST WANNA SEE IN THE IN
THE EXAMPLES THAT YOU USE IN
THE OTHER EXAMPLES THAT HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED HERE ON THE
FLOOR THIS MORNING THOSE ARE
EGGS REGIS ABUSES OF. POWER
REALLY BECAUSE WHEN SOMEBODY'S
GIVING THE APPRAISAL THEY HAVE
A POWER- IN THAT SITUATION AND.
YOU KNOW I THINK MAYBE THOSE
NEED TO MOVE IN THAT ARENA- OR
THE AREA OF DISCIPLINARY ACTION
BY THE BOARDS. I HAVE NOT
SUPPORTED CONTINUING EDUCATION-
LEGISLATION I WILL I'M NOT
GONNA SUPPORT. I'M NOT
SUPPORTING THIS BILL EITHER
RIGHT AND I MEAN I APOLOGIZE I
DIDN'T GET TO END TO THE
COMMITTEE ALSO I DIDN'T GET A
CHANCE TO EXPLAIN THAT TO. MS
BURKE EARLIER- BUT WE HAVE A
BOARD- WE HAVE A SUNSET REVIEW
THAT I THINK ARE THE PROPER
COURSES FOR THE CONTINUED
EDUCATION TO BE EXAMINED AND
BROUGHT INTO- YOU KNOW APPROVED
AND INPUT AND I JUST KIND OF
SEE. ON YOU KNOW DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS NOT PARTICULARLY
THIS ONE BUT YOU KNOW OF OTHER
SITUATIONS WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE'S. MEDDLING INTO
THE LICENSING OF DIFFERENT-
PROFESSIONS IT I THINK
SOMETIMES. WE NEED TO LEAVE
THAT EXPERTISE TO THE BOARD AND
SO I JUST WANT TO EXPLAIN WHY
I'M NOT SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY- AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT.
BECAUSE OF YOU OR BECAUSE OF
THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION I'M
I'M JUST HAVING A CHALLENGE
WITH CONTINUING EDUCATION
STUFF- OVERALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR JOHN CENTER
PARKER DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT
QUESTION OR CONCERN. NO I WAS
GOING TO WITHDRAW I WOULD I
JUST I- SO SEE MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE THE MAID AND WE HAD THERE
HEARD THE SPECIFIC EXAMPLES
FROM FROM STOCKTON HERE I THINK
THAT WERE VERY. COMPELLING
JUDGMENTS AT PRECIADO AUTHOR
BRING THIS FORWARD AND LOOKING
TO ADDRESS THIS AND I THINK THE
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS IT THROUGH.
THE CONTENTS AS ACTUALLY MAKING
PEOPLE PHYSICALLY GO THROUGH
SOMETHING IS A POSITIVE STEP
AND I HOPE IT WORKS AND IF NOT
WE'LL COME BACK WITH A MALE
STRIPPER REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR. AND WHAT HE'S TRYING TO
DO HERE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. FIGURE
GERMAN I WOULD JUST. SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE COMMENTS
AND I THINK THAT IT CERTAINLY
IS WHAT UNDER. FANS THE NEED
FOR THE SPELL- FIRST AT HOME
WITH MY OWN CHIEF OF STAFF. WHO
DESCRIBED AN INCIDENT MUCH
LIKE. SENATOR EDWARDS IS
DESCRIBED WITH THE MAYOR. OF
FORMER MAYOR. AND YOU KNOW IT
HAPPENS IN A LOT OF TIMES
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HOW TO REACH
OUT AND GET RECOURSE. TO
ADDRESS THE GRIEVANCE- THIS
BILL IS A MODEST UP. TO TRY TO
DO THAT. AND I RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS CHARGED WITH
SUNSET REVIEW. AND THAT THERE
IS A PROCESS OF GOING THROUGH
THAT- BUT SOMETIMES LIFE
HAPPENS IN SUCH A WAY THAT IT
DOESN'T LINE UP WITH THE TIMING
OF THE SCHEDULED. FOR SUNSET
REVIEWS AND SO THE GIVEN THE
NATURE OF THE IMPACT THAT IS
HAVING TO CALIFORNIANS TODAY AS
WE SPEAK. THE COUPLE IN MARIN
COUNTY. THEIR HOME ONCE THIS
THING WAS BROUGHT TO LIGHT AND
WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO IS
BASICALLY. PRESENT TO THE TO
THE APPRAISAL COMMITTEE. THAT
THERE WAS A WHITE FAMILY. IT
WAS LIVING IN THE HOME. THEY
TOOK DOWN EVERYTHING THAT ROOF
REFLECTED THEIR ETHNICITY. AND
THEN I HAD A FRIEND. STEP IN
THE PRICE OF THE HOME WENT FROM
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND APPRAISAL
TWO MILLION. SO THAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IT IS NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE TO VERY TIMELY AND
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR J. C. CENTER DOT IS
WILLING TO MAKE A MOTION WHO
WILL BY SENATOR DODD. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFERRED THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FOUR EIGHT
DO YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY MEMBERS
PLEASE HAVE YOUR MICROPHONES ON
FOR THE VOTE SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR YOU. RALPH SYME ROSS I
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
IBEATS. BAIT HI BACKER HI.
BECKER I DIED I THOUGHT I ADMIN
BY ADMIN I HER TADO JONES NO.
JONES NO LLEVA. MAN HI MAN I
KNEW MAN HI NEWMAN I A CHILL
ABODE HAN. PHOTO IS EIGHT TO
ONE SUFFICIENT TO MOVE OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SIR LET'S MOVE ON TO
YOUR FINAL ITEM FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWELVE NINE SEVEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES- PATIENCE AS WE MAKE
OUR WAY TO OUR LAST BILL TODAY
WHICH IS A B. TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN. TWELVE NINETY NINETY
SEVEN WILL CLARIFY THAT I'D BE
MAY FINANCE HOUSING AS PART OF
AN OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE PROJECT
ONLY WHEN THE HOUSING ELEMENT
IS REQUIRED. FOR THE OPERATION
OF THE PROJECT. ADDITIONALLY NO
PART OF THE HOUSING ELEMENT CAN
BE FINANCED WITH TAX EXEMPT
BONDS TO ENSURE THERE IS NO
CONFLICT WITH OTHER STATE
HOUSING FINANCE PROGRAMS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW I BANK IS
AUTHORISED TO FINANCE A WIDE
VARIETY OF PUBLIC AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS BUT
EXPRESSLY EXCLUDES HOUSING
WITHOUT DEFINING THE SCOPE. OF
THE RESTRICTION OR A CLEAR
INDICATION OF WHY. THE ABSOLUTE
PROHIBITION ON HOUSING IN THE
EYE BANK- CREATES A FINANCING
GAP. BUT EXCLUDING ALL PROJECTS
THAT CONTAIN ANY ELEMENTS OF
HOUSING. FOR EXAMPLE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE FACILITY HOUSING OR
SHOULD SAY FACULTY HOUSING. FOR
SCHOOL'S GROUNDS KEEPERS OR
OPERATOR FACILITY SUMMER CAMPS
AND YOUTH CAMPS. AND TREATMENT
RELATED HOUSING FOR SOCIAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS CANNOT BE
FINANCED BY I. BANK. UNDER
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THESE
PROJECTS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE. AS
A FINANCIER OF LAST RESORT FOR
MANY PROJECTS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW I. BANKS ADD. AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN THE STATES TO
A BELT TO INCREASE MORE
TARGETED AND CREATIVE
APPROACHES TO HOUSING. TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME NUMBERED MEDICINE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT-
WELL HE WILL BE CALLING IN TO
GIVE TESTIMONY. I THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SERVICE
PRESENT PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MR
HOLDEN- I THINK ACT PROVIDES A
CRUCIAL FINANCING MECHANISM FOR
PUBLIC DEVELOPMENT FACILITIES
THAT SOMETIMES INCLUDES AN
ELEMENT OF HOW THE- D. A. IS
HERE TO SUPPORT A B. TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN BECAUSE IT WOULD
CLARIFY THE AUTHORITY OF THE I
THINK. TO INCLUDE FINANCING
PROJECTS WITH HOUSING ELEMENTS
WITH THE ELEMENTS ARE NECESSARY
FOR THE OPERATION OF THE
FINANCED PROJECT. THE
CLASSIFICATION WILL HAVE THE
EFFECT OF MOVING PROJECTS ALONG
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
PROHIBITED. A. B. TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN MAKES MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
NO PART OF THE HOUSING ELEMENT
CAN BE FINANCED WITH TAX EXEMPT
BONDS. BY CLARIFYING THE TERM
HOUSING UNDER THE I THINK ACT
THIS BILL EXPANDS HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE STATE
WHILE ENSURING THERE'S NO
CONFLICT WITH OTHER HOUSING
FINANCE PROGRAM. THEREFORE
EIGHTY TWELVE NINETY SEVEN WILL
BE A PART OF THE SOLUTION AND
CREATING MORE HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THE
CALIFORNIA SO DESPERATELY NEED.
AND FOR THESE REASONS THE
CALIFORNIA PARDON APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AIBO. THANK YOU
LIST TO THE GALLERY TO SEE IF
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THERE I SEE NO WITNESSES
IDENTIFYING THEMSELVES. LET'S
TURN YOUR ROOM ONE TWELVE TO
SEE IF TEIR WITNESSES THEIR
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A
B. TWELVE NINETY SEVEN I SEE
NONE. LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOUR NINETY SEVEN WILL PROCEED.
THANK YOU TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME SO.
CURRENTLY NONE IN Q. THANK YOU
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FIRST IN THE GALLERY.
I SEE NO WITNESSES IDENTIFYING
THEMSELVES LET'S TURN TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE WERE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN. SAYING NO
WITNESSES LET'S TURN TO THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN. WE WILL MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU AND PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME SO.
AND CURRENTLY NOT IN Q. THANK
YOU MODERATOR LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER. COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS. FIRST STARTING WITH
SENATOR BACKER FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR MAN. THANK YOU SIR I'M
I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE SO I WOULD
LIKE THE IDEA SURE CAN YOU GIVE
SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT ARE THE
KINDS OF PROJECTS THAT WOULD
THEN BE PERMITTED. UNDER THIS
BILL THAT MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
PERMITTED OTHERWISE. FIFTY
PLEASE PUT THE SEVEN MEMBER YES
THERE ARE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT- AND MY- THAT INITIAL
PRESENTATION IT IS- PROVIDING
AS AN EXAMPLE OF FACULTY
HOUSING FOR SCHOOLS-
GROUNDSKEEPERS FOR OPERATORS OF
FACILITIES SUMMER YOUTH CAMPS
SO IT'S REALLY A SET THAT
REALLY LOOKING AT THE HOUSING
BEING SORT OF A AN ANCILLARY
PART TO THE DEVELOPMENT SO
WHERE THERE'S A IMPORTANT
HOUSING IS AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT
THEY CAN BE RIGHT NOW I CAN NOT
BE INCLUDED. AND SO WHAT WAS
BEEN SEEN WITH THE-
ADMINISTRATION- THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WERE SEEN OTHER OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME IS HOW THE I.
BANK- WAS NOT ACTUALLY GETTING.
DONE WHAT I THINK OF FOLKS WERE
HOPING THAT I COULD ALSO GET
DONE FOR HOUSING AND SO. WHEN
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
ARE POOR BUT IT WAS CHAPTER. I
A. B. FIFTY SIX A BILL I
AUTHORED IT SORT OF STARTED TO
MAKE OUR WAY INTO THE SPACE BY
ALLOWING. INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE
INCLUDED SO- SEWER LINES
COMMUNICATION LINES- US TRAFFIC
SIGNAL LINES THINGS OF THAT
NATURE COULD. BE UTILIZED FOR
HOUSING RELATED BUT THERE AND
THIS WAS THE GAP THAT NEEDS TO
BE THE NEXT STEP. AND SO NOT TO
COMPETE WITH OTHER HOUSING TYPE
PROJECTS THAT ARE. MORE
EXCLUSIVELY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. THIS WAS AT LEAST
ALLOWING A LITTLE BIT MORE
LATITUDE FOR I. BASIC FUNDS TO
BE USED FOR HOUSING RELATED.
PROJECTS. I THINK I ALSO LOOK
AT IT FROM THE STANDPOINT OF.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE- WE TALKED
ABOUT SCHOOLS WE HAVE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. IN OUR
DISTRICT A PASSING CITY
COLLEGE. THAT IS LOOKING TO.
FIND LAND. THAT THEY COULD
BUILD TRANSPORTATION RELATED
LIKE PARKING BUT ALSO TO BUILD
STUDENT HOUSING. SO IT WOULD
MAYBE BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ABOUT TO FIT UNDER THE
DEFINITION. AS LONG AS THIS-
STRUCTURED IN THE RIGHT WAY BUT
THAT'S THE KIND OF USE THAT I
THINK WE'RE HAVING IN MIND.
THAT THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH CURRENTLY
DOES NOT. THANKS MAKES LESS
SENSE TO ME I MOVE THE BILL
WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER CENTER MAN. RIGHT
I THANK YOU SO NUMBER I-
APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL- ATTRIBUTES THE CLIP THE
CLERK THOUGHTFULNESS THAT WENT
INTO IT AND WOULD ASK THE
VEHICLE OUT THERE. I WANT TO
MAKE IT THREE FOR THREE YEARS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MENDOZA. I SEE NO OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
OF SOMEONE MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR BECKER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PHYLUM
NINE AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN DO
YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING ROTH- ROSS
HI MELINDA'S ARCHULETA ALL
RIGHT- CHILLOUT IBEATS. VOTING
RECORD. RIGHT BACKER I DAUGHTER.
DAUGHTER HI ADMIN HI ADNAN I
HER TADO. JONES HI JONES I.
LEIVA MAIN MAN HI NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT NEW MAN I I'D SHOW ABODE
HAN. BILL IS A VOTE SO IT'S
ENOUGH TO MOVE OUT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER
HOLD A NICE JOB THANK YOU
SENATORS MEMBERS WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO BEFORE WE TAKE OUR
NEXT- ITEM WHICH IS. ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW WE'RE GOING TO QUICKLY.
CALL THE ROLL ON THE BILLS THAT
WE'VE CONSIDERED WE HAVE
MEMBERS WHO WILL HAVE TO LEAVE
FOR A COMMITTEE IN ABOUT. SEVEN
MINUTES OR SO LET'S START WITH
THE- CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN AB TEN SEVENTY TWO
THEIR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR COLLEAGUES. COLLEAGUES
IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CENTER
ARCHULETA THANK YOU. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ROCK NINE ROSS HI
MELENDEZ ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I'D BEATS. EIGHT HI BACKER
BACKER HI DAUGHTER DAUGHTER HI
ADNAN HI A MAN I HER TADO JONES.
JONES I. LEIVA. MIN MAIN HI
NEWMAN NEWMAN I SHOW A BOGEY
HAN. THE CIRCULAR HAS NINE
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT ITEM
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. WE NEED A
MOTION IT HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ARCH ALETTA. THE MOTION
IS TO PRESS THREE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PHILAE TO
ONE EIGHTY SIX NINETY DO YOU
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROSS HI ROSS I MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA- CHILLOUT IBEATS.
BEATS HI BACKER BACKER I'D DODD
DOTD I A MAN A MAN I HER TADO.
JONES JONES I LEAVE A MAN MAN I
KNEW MEN NEW MAN I A SHOW
ABOUT- GOOD HAND. I HAVE A.
NINE BILL IS NINE VOTES IMAGE
TO GET OUT WILL THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM
IS VIOLATED NUMBER TWO. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE A. B.
FOURTEEN ZERO SEVEN MOTION BY
SENATOR NEWMAN MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
VIOLATE M. Q. AV FORTINO
SEVENTY PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH ROSS HI
ROSS HI MELINDA'S ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA IBD'S. BEATS I BACKER.
BACKER I. DODD. DODD I EXAMINE
HEY MAN I HEARD HATO JONES.
JONES NO LLEVA MAIN MAN HI
NEWMAN NEWMAN I BOUGHT IS EIGHT
TO ONE SUFFICIENTLY DURABLE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHANNEL
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINE ONE.
CENTERS WE NEED A MOTION. US
SENATOR NEWMAN MOVES TO BUILD A
BOOK THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FAIL ITEMS THREE A. B.
SIX NINE ONE DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH IRA ROTH
IRA MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA IBEATS. BEATS I
BACKER. BECKER I DIED DONNA HI
AIKMAN. A MAN I HER TADO JONES
JONES HI LISA. MAIN MAN HI
NIMIN NEWMAN I A. CHOU ABODE
HAN BILL OF NINE VOTES
SUFFICIENT TO MOVE OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. I JUST HAVE TO GET
THROUGH IT BECAUSE THEY'RE PART
OF. HAVE. LET'S LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM TEN ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE THREE ZERO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVIN. EIGHTY NINE THREE
ZERO CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO
ZERO MELINDA'S BACKER. BACKER
HI HER TADO LEVER THAT SHOW A
BOGUS HAN. THERE WAS- VOTE IS
NINE ZERO WILL HOLD THE MATTER
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
LET'S
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR SEVEN ONE SURE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES
THINK VERY MUCH ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT- FIRST OFF THE THANK
YOU AGAIN TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HELPING TO
PARTNER WITH THE BUREAU OF
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
CONSUMER PROTECTION. ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR IT CAN BE QUITE DAUNTING
FOR SO MANY CONSUMERS TO TAKE
IN THEIR CAR FOR AUTO REPAIR
NOT KNOWING WHAT- THEY ARE
SUBJECTED TO AND YET THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. HAVE A DIGITAL
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- SPECIAL THANKS
TO DANIEL SIRES IN THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
FOR HELPING WORK ON THIS OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS WITH ME AND
SUPPORT ARE TWO INDIVIDUALS- TO
IT ALSO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TECH
MAULDIN OFF AS WELL AS GARY
CONOVER. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SIR WITNESSES PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SHE
ACKNOWLEDGED ON UP ON BEHALF OF
THE AUTOMOTIVE SERVICE COUNCIL
TO CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
AUTOMOTIVE BUSINESS COALITION
CALIFORNIA AUTOBODY ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA TIRE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK-
SYMBOL MENLO AND STAFF WERE
WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS SINCE LAST YEAR'S
EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FOUR-
SIMPLY BEEN LOW HELD OFF ON
THAT BILL AND ALLOWED B. A. R.
TO DEVELOP THE- AUTO REPAIR
SHOP- AUTO SHOP LOCATOR
PROGRAM. WHICH IS A MOBILE LIFE
THE MOBILE FRIENDLY SEARCH TOOL
WHICH ALLOWS CONSUMERS TO
PERFORM LOCATION BASED SEARCHES
FOR SHOP THE RESULT AND VERIFY
IF THE REPAIR SHOP THE SUBJECT
TO DISCIPLINARY ACTION WHAT
THIS BILL WILL DO WILL ENHANCE
THE AUTO SHOP LOCATOR PROGRAM
BY HELPING CONSUMERS IDENTIFY
REPAIR SOPS. THAT HAVE
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED IN THE
INDUSTRY ACCEPTED EDUCATIONAL
CERTIFICATES IMPROVES B. R.
CITATION FINE PROGRAM BY
CREATING AN INDEPENDENT PANEL
TO REVIEW CITATION APPEALS. IT
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
REPAIR SHOP TO ATTEND REMEDIAL
TRAINING FOR MINOR
DOCUMENTATION AND RECORD
KEEPING VIOLATIONS SIMILAR TO
TRAFFIC SCHOOL OVERALL THE BILL
ENHANCES CONSUMER PROTECTION
WHILE BALANCING THE INTERESTS
OF SMALL BUSINESS REPAIR SHOPS
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT I
VOTE ON THE BILL. THANK YOU I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING GARY CON WITH THE A. W.
WAIVER. OUR PARTS INDUSTRY THE
AUTO CARE ASSOCIATION. IN
NINETEEN NINETY OF THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL TO
THE GOVERNOR- AND BILL EIGHTY
NINETEEN NINETY THE FED UP WITH
THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR. IT LAMP AND BRAKE
INSPECTION PROGRAM. FOR SOUTH
TITLE VEHICLES. AFTER THIRTY
YEARS WE SUGGEST- WITHIN THE
BILL THAT THE PROGRAM BEING
RENAMED THE CONFECTION OF
SAFETY PROGRAM AND PROVIDE BAR
WITH THE AUTHORITY. TO HOLD
PUBLIC HEARINGS. CONSIDERED
EXPANDING THE PROGRAM BEYOND
LAMPS AND BREAKS AND CONSUMERS
SEMESTER AUTOMOBILES TO REMOVE
THE SALVAGE REFERENCE TO THE
TITLE ON THEIR CAR- WITH THAT
SAID- THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BILL
AND I APPRECIATE THE- FIRST
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR LET'S
TURN TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AND SUPPORT. I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE LET'S TURN TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE TO CHECK TO SEE
THAT THERE ANY WTNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVEN ONE THEIR SIGNAL WOULD
THIS IS LET'S TURN TO THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT WITNESSES. WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR SEVEN ONE WE WILL
PROCEED. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME SO. AND
YOU HAVE THE LINE ONE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU GO
TO. I THE- NEXT PLEASE I KNOW
IT NINE FURTHER AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION FIRST WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION SEE
NO WITNESSES IDENTIFYING
THEMSELVES LET'S TURN TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. CHECK TO SEE IF
THERE ANY WITNESSES THERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE I
SEE NO WITNESSES TURNING TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVEN ONE WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH THOSE
WITNESSES. THANK YOU AND PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND CURRENTLY NOBODY IN
JUNE. PERFECT LET'S TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. GUARDING
THIS MEASURE. SENATOR EDMUND.%
SIR EDMUND MOVES THE BILL.
SOMEONE MEMBER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE EXACTLY YES VERY
VOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR REAGAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE T. PASSING REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
ROTH HI ROSS I'M MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA IBEATS.
BACKER. BACKER I'D DIED. DOT I
MEAN. EIGHT MEN I HER TADO
JONES LEVI MEN. MAN I KNEW MAN.
NEW MAN I SHOW A BOGUS. CAN CAN
I A TO A BOGUS I. BILL HAS NINE
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROPE IN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. PHYLUM NUMBER
TWELVE SIR YOU MAY NOT PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIX TWO WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR FIRST LIKE
OFF TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN ANALYSIS ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SIXTY TWO WILLHELP
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE. MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES
ASSISTING US IN THIS TIME OF
NEED SPECIFICALLY DURING
COVERT. AND WITH ME IN SUPPORT
ON THE LINE TO DISCUSS THE
NECESSITY OF THE BILL IS A
MEMBER OF YOUR NECK MICHELLE
BAKA REGISTERED NURSE AT KAISER
FONTANA AS WELL AS DR ANTONIO
HERNANDEZ COMMENTARY AND IT'S
EASY ALL THIS AT KAISER IN LOS
ANGELES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU SIR WITNESSES
YOU MAY PROCEED. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS- ACTUALLY-
GROBLER ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
NURSES ASSOCIATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA UNION OF. HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS MACHEL BACH IS
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS AND COULD
NOT. MAKE IT THISMORNING-
CHAIRMAN ROTH AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK THIS
MORNING. AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW OR THREE PP
FIVE SIX TWO WHICH WILL.
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR HEALTH CARE WORKERS NURSES
AND PROVIDERS. I'M SPEAKING FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
NURSES AND HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS AND ACTS AS WELL
AS THOSE HEALTHCARE WORKERS
THAT SHARE CHALLENGES AND
CONCERNS. IT WILL SOON BE
SIXTEEN MONTHS THAT WE HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH THE PANDEMIC
THAT HAS IMPACTED ALL OF HEALTH
CARE. FOR THE MEMBERS WE
REPRESENT THIS WAS AN
ADDITIONAL ASSAULT ON AN
INDUSTRY THAT ALREADY SUFFERED
FROM A SHORTAGE OF NURSES. AND
PROVIDERS LONG HOURS COURSE
THAT THE HEAVY. WORKLOAD STRESS
AND BURN OUT. STRUGGLES OVER
THE LACK OF PPP. BILL FOURTEEN
OF NINETY MASS AND CONTACT
CHANGING THIS. RECOMMENDS AND
GUIDELINES CONTRIBUTED TO
CONCERNS AROUND PERSONAL INJURY
TO CARE GIVERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WELL ROUNDED AND MANY
OF OUR PARTY TO HOSPITALS IN
THE MONTH OF DECEMBER IT WAS
APPARENT TO ME THAT. CARE
GIVERS WERE WORKING WITHOUT
EMOTIONAL OR PSYCHOLOGICAL
SUPPORT WHAT KERRY BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN PATIENTS THAT WERE
CRITICALLY ILL. AND MANY OF
WHOM DID NOT SURVIVE. NURSES
WERE OPERATING ALL ASPECTS OF
CARE THAT WOULD NORMALLY BE
PROVIDED. BY SEVERAL CLINICAL
SERVICES. AND HELP YOUR WORK
WERE TO PUT TWO AREAS AND
WORKING OVERFLOWING MANY ICY
USE. EITHER SAYS WE'RE ASKED TO
CARE FOR COMPROMISED PATIENTS
BEYOND THEIR EXPERTISE. BUT
FEAR OF MAKING MISTAKES AND
PUTTING PATIENTS FURTHER AT
RISK BEGAN TO BE A SOURCE OF
ADDITIONAL STRESS. HERE
REPRISAL AND LOTS OF LIFE
INSURANCE THE WINTER MONTHS TO
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
WHAT A SOURCE OF CONCERN TO THE
WORKFORCE. STORIES OF
EXHAUSTION LOTS OF PATIENTS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE ALLEGED
DEPRESSION SUICIDE AND HOPES
FORCED NURSES AND OTHER
PROVIDERS TO LEAVE THEIR
PROFESSION. WITH SHORTAGES AND
RETIREMENTS IN MOTION WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO LEAVE OUR REMAINING
WORKFORCE WITHOUT THE
APPROPRIATE EMOTIONAL NO AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SUPPORT. WE NEED
THE SAME LEVEL OF COMMITMENT TO
PROTECT THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
THOSE THAT ARE STILL WORKING TO
CARE FOR PATIENTS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THAT SAME LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT THAT RETURNED ARSES
AND HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
BACK TO THE WORK SITE DAY AFTER
DAY DESPITE THE FEAR AND
UNCERTAINTY. WE ALL KNOW THE
ENDEMIC IT'S STILL WITH US WITH
A COMMUNITY DIVIDED AROUND
VACCINATIONS AND A MORE
CONTAGIOUS AND FASTER SPREADING
VIRUS. THIS ADDS TO CONCERNS
AROUND THE FUTURE MENTAL HEALTH
OF OUR WORKFORCE AND FOR MANY.
AN INABILITY TO COPE AND. MOVE
ON. WE NEED YOUR HELP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I. ASK FOR A
NIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT. HELLO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
ANTONIO HERNANDEZ CONTE AND I'M
A CARDIAC ANESTHESIOLOGIST AT
THE KAISER PERMANENTE A LOS
ANGELES MEDICAL CENTER I AM
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS LEGISLATIVE
AND PRACTICE AFFAIRS DIVISION
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS IS PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR AT FIVE SIX TWO.
PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS ARE
GUARDIANS OF PATIENT SAFETY IN
THE OPERATING ROOM IN THE
DELIVERY ROOM IN INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT IN PAIN MANAGEMENT CLINIC
AND DURING THE PAST YEAR ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS UNDERGO OVER
TWELVE YEARS OF EDUCATION AND
TRAINING TO NAVIGATE CRITICAL
LIFE AND DEATH MOMENTS IN THE
OPERATING ROOM AND MULTIPLE
PROCEDURAL AND SURGICAL AREAS.
THEY ALSO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND SERVICE- WE
MANAGEMENT EXPERTS FOR THE
SICKEST OF PATIENTS DIAGNOSED
WITH AND SUFFERING FROM PELVIC
NINETEEN. HOWEVER TRADITIONS
LIKE US NURSES AND OTHER
FRONTLINE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
PROVIDERS AND WORKERS HAD BEEN
UNDER EXTRAORDINARY STRESS
DURING THE PAST YEAR WORKING
LONGER HOURS DAY AFTER DAY. IN
TOUGHER CONDITIONS THAN EVER
BEFORE. THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WANTS TO
MAKE SURE THEY ALL HAVE ACCESS
TO EFFECTIVE AND CONFIDENTIAL
MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
RESOURCES. IF NEEDED AND WHEN
NEEDED. WE NEED PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS ANOTHER
FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
TO STAY PHYSICALLY HEALTHY AND
MENTALLY STRONG SO THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE BEST
CARE POSSIBLE FOR THEIR
PATIENTS. THEREFORE THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS STRONGLY
BELIEVES THAT EIGHTY FIVE SIX
TWO WILL CREATE NEW TOOLS TO
MANAGE BURN OUT AND TREAT TREAT
PROLONGED STRESS AND TRAUMA
ASSOCIATED WITH SEEING FIRST
HAND THE DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN. ALL FRONT LINE
WORKERS DESERVE TO RECUPERATE
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH RENEWED
RESILIENCY AS WE ALL RECOVER
FROM THE DEVASTATING IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA.
LASTLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
ESPECIALLY THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SLOW AND FLORA FOR THEIR
EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
ITEM ON AB FIVE SIX TWO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU LET'S TURN TO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY AND
SUPPORT. I SEE NO WITNESSES
IDENTIFYING THEMSELVES
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIX TWO
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF I SEE
NO WITNESSES. TURNING TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SIX TWO WE WILL
PROCEED. THANK YOU AGAIN IT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO WELL FIRST
CAR LINE UP ONE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
BIRTH PRISCILLA KIOSK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION PSYCHIATRIST THE
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NINE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COLORING ON THE APP THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES ARE GOING FOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. IN LINE ONE A ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. H. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR MEMBERS BRIGHT DOUGHERTY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. AT ONE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TO RICHARD C. WERE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
AND ONE AWAIT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING ADRIAN MARKET WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSORED THE
BELL AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. AND
THAT'S NINE ONE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY
THREE. HI OUT SIMON OF THE WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. LAST FOUR LINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
COLQUITT WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT. THANK
YOU AND NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FIRST
BEGINNING WITH THE GALLERY I
SEE NO WITNESSES IDENTIFYING
THEMSELVES OR ANY WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIX TWO
SEEING NO WITNESSES THERE LET'S
TURN TO THE TELECONFERENCING
SERVICED MODERATOR ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE SIX TWO. WILL MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IN EARLY NO
PARKERS AND Q. PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU THANK YOU LET'S BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS REGARDING
THIS MEASURE. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP THAT SENSE OFF
YOUR DOCTOR PAN YOU'RE BACK IN
THE CORNER NO PHONE JACK WITH
BUSINESSES ACTUALLY I THINK I
CLOSE TO YOUR USUAL SETON
HEALTH COMMITTEE BUT- THANK
YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH A CHAIR-
SIMILAR FIRST OF ALL I WANT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- BOTH YOU
AND- SUMMER FLOOR I MEAN JUST
KIND OF IT IS- BECAUSE
TREMENDOUS TRAUMA TO. PEOPLE ON
THE FRONT LINES AND HEALTH
CARE- AND- AND THAT TRAUMA IS
GOING TO BE ONGOING THE PTSD.
FROM THAT'S HAPPENED OVER THE
PAST YEAR SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I DID I DID JUST
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
DRESSING A FEW OF THE THINGS
NOTED IN THE- COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SO- ONE WAS SAY
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL. ACTUALLY
MAKES IT A MISDEMEANOR FOR. ICE
FALLS FIND APPLICATION
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
ANYONE FALSIFIED APPLICATIONS
BUT- I DON'T KNOW WHETHER SUCH
A PENALTY IS APPROPRIATE WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE- AND THEN ALSO
PERHAPS ALSO SPEAKS- THE TOP IN
TERMS OF THE SERVICE IS
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE AND WOULD
THOSE BE. WELL I'D BE CONCERNED
IF THEY WERE PAID A LICENSING
FEES- BECAUSE I KNOW WE'RE
READY STRUGGLING WITH-
LICENSING FEES GOING UP. AND I
DO UNDERSTAND THE DCA DOES HAVE
LIKE A MASTER CONTRACT TO HELP
FOR THE FRILLS THAT PERHAPS-
SOME ALTERNATIVE SOURCES OF
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
SO IF YOU COULD JUST. SPEAK TO
THOSE THINGS THAT PRECEDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TALK ABOUT BEST- IT IS AND THEN-
INTRODUCTION THE BILL WAS THAT
OF A FELONY- NOW SEVEN
MISDEMEANOR BUT HAPPY TO
CONTINUE ON TO. FIND
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET AT THE
CRUX OF THE ISSUE- SUPPORT GOOD
ACTORS WHILE ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS AN ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. THAT IS NOT THE
DESIRE TO BE PUNITIVE BY ANY
MEANS- BUT IT'S BECAUSE IT
COUNTED THE PROCESS. I'M HAPPY
TO HAVE THE DIGITAL
CONVERSATIONS EVEN TO LOWER THE
AMOUNT AS WELL TOO A SPECIFIC
ON THE ON THE FINES- AND THEN
WITH RESPECT TO THE FEE
INCREASE. WE DO NOT DESIRE TO
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL FEE
INCREASES AS ALSO LISTED IN
ALICE'S SO- WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS MOVING
FORWARD. AS WELLS AS DCA TO
INSURE THAT WE HAVE THE TYPE OF
INTEGRITY WILL NOT PUTTING AN
ADDITIONAL BURDEN. A
SPECIFICALLY- THE THAT IS THE
ISSUE AS IT MISSED DENOUNCES ON
THE FISCAL ISSUE- WE HAVEN'T.
IDENTIFIED A FISCAL. SOURCE YET
BUT THE LESSONS IN THE POLICY
WE HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
THESE CONVERSATIONS TO ADDRESS
THE SIGNIFICANT NEED.
ESPECIALLY PORT AUTHORITY YOUR
CONFERENCE. IS ENDING NOW
PLEASE HANG UP. THANK YOU SO
VERY LOW AND- YEAH I THINK THAT
THE ISSUE THE MISDEMEANORS ALSO
THAT SOMEONE ACTUALLY NEEDS
MENTAL HEALTH. HELP WE DON'T
DISCOURAGE THEM BECAUSE IT FROM
FROM DOING THAT THINKING THAT
MAYBE THERE MIGHT BE A PENALTY
IF THEY MISREPRESENT THEMSELVES
OR SOMEONE THINKS THAT WAY. THE
TIME WITH YOU THINK SOME OF IT
I THINK OTHER MECHANISMS STILL
FILTER OUT LIKE. THAT AND I'M
NOT SURE WHY SOMEONE WOULD TRY
TO- YES. THE DETENTION WE FAKED
THE SYSTEM MAYBE I'M BEING
NAIVE ABOUT THAT BUT- HEY. YOU
KNOW I HATE IT I WANT TO BE
SURE WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO RE
HARD ENOUGH FOR HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO ADMIT THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. SO WE
DON'T WANT. TO MINIMIZE
DESPAIRS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- DOCTOR
PAN LET'S TURN TO- CENTER ADMIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESEARCHER
I THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL. THE
FAMILY MEMBER LOW I GUESS MY
ONE QUESTION WOULD BE ONE OF
THE- WHAT. AID THERE'S ALREADY
A LOT OF EAP PROGRAM SO IF YOU
COULD MAYBE IN YOUR CLOTHES
JUST TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW THIS IS ALREADY. THIS IS
DIFFERENT FROM SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED AND I KNOW- THERE
HAVE BEEN VARIOUS YOU KNOW.
THINGS BEGAN TO BE ABLE TO
DRESSES ISSUE BUT I GUESS AND
THEN ANOTHER ONE MY QUESTION IS
JUST WHAT I SEE IS SOMEBODY OF
AN OMISSION IS THAT. WHAT YOU
HAVE ALL THE BOARDS THAT WILL
BE COVERED BY THIS AND WELL MY
PROFESSION. OR TO BUILD. THAT
THE B. B. S. AS IN IN IN THERE.
SO I MEAN. THERAPIST AND HEALTH
CARE- MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
ALSO NEED. HELP SO I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT COULD BE A POTENTIAL A
MISSION THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO
INCLUDE. A COMPASSION FATIGUE
ALSO. IMPACTS OF THOSE THAT ARE
DEALING WITH THE- THE TRAUMA.
OF OTHER CARE GIVERS SO I WOULD
JUST UP AND MAKE THAT POINT.
ABOUT IF YOU COULD JUST ADDRESS
HOW THIS IS DIFFERENT FROM ALL
THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE.
OUT THERE. AND THEN MAYBE
PERHAPS YOUR WILLINGNESS TO.
ADD IN THE B. B. S. OR- OR A-
THIRD CONVERSATION THAT WAY.
WHY NOT. SURE HAPPY TO DO THAT
A CLOSE INTERACTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR ADMIN CENTER BATES. I
GOT MY QUESTION THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER. WE JUST CLEARED
THE DECK COLLEAGUES ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS-
DOCTOR PAN MICHAELIS SAYS MOVE
THE BILLS THANK YOU SIR. SEVEN
MEMBER LOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR AGAIN TO SENATOR OUR DOCTOR
PANS- COMMENTS- WE'D LOVE TO
GET YOU TO WORK WITH YOU TO
ADDRESS THAT OF COURSE THEY
GIVEN THE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE TO ALLOW FOR THE
FACILITATION OF THAT. AND
MINIMIZE AS MUCH HARM AS
POSSIBLE ESPECIALLY TO REMOVE
AS MUCH STIGMA TO THOSE-
SPECIFICALLY NEED- AND TO
ADDRESS- CENTERED EGGMAN'S-
QUESTION- NOT ALL THE TIME WITH
THE E. PROGRAMS ARE ADEQUATE
NOT THAT MIGHT BE SOME
ADDITIONAL OR SOMETIMES IT
TAKES LONGER TO BE ABLE TO SEEK
OUT. THE ASSISTANCE I KNOW
SPECIFICALLY I'VE HAD LOVED
ONES WHO SOUGHT TO USE THE AP
DURING CUB PANDEMIC BUT DID NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO DO SO THE
SCHEDULING WAS ALL BOOKED AND
THEY COULDN'T FIND A PROVIDER
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY ACCEPT THEM
IN THE PROGRAM SO THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO ENHANCE AND ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE MIGHT BE
ADDITIONAL NEED. TO HELP WITH
THE ON THE GRIDLOCK THAT MIGHT
OCCUR- SECONDLY WE WERE MINDFUL
OF THE COST- AND INCREASING IT-
WE'RE FOCUSED ON THE ICY USE
INDIVIDUALS AND I SHOES BUT I'M
DELIGHTED TO HAVE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE OF COURSE AS YOU WELL
KNOW THEN INCREASES COST SO.
HAVE TO WORK FURTHER WITH YOU
TO ADDRESS THE THAT SPECIFIC
PROVISION AS WELL TOO BUT WE
FOCUS ON THE IC SUFFERS BUT
HAPPY TO EXPLORE ADDITIONAL
OPTIONS. WITH YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. SOCIAL WORKERS
A NICE USE. THEY'RE THE ONES
DOING THE MOVIE.
THANK YOU FOR
CALLING THE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE WERE BACK ON THE RECORD
IN ORDER FOR THE
TELECONFERENCE- SERVICES AND WE
APPARENTLY ARE SO WE CAN TAKE A
VOTE. THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR PAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FIVE
EIGHT AM TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY TWO DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ROSS HI. ROSS I'M
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. BEATS FIVE
BEATS HI BECKER. BACKER I'D
DODD I DON HI ADNAN BY. ADMIN
HI HER TADO JONES. LEVI HI LEVI
ICEMEN. NEWMAN NEW MAN I AND
SHOW A VOGUE. A CHILL ABODE IPN
HI HE AND I. BILL IS NINE VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. SIR YOU HAVE
ONE LAST BILL ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
ZERO EIGHT FOUR PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RICHER FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THE FINAL ITEM TODAY
AND STARTING OFF BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- ON
THE LAST DAY OF PRIDE MONTH
HAPPY PRIDE. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE RETAILERS WITH OVER
FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES- TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A GENERAL
NEUTRAL RETAIL SECTION OF TOYS
AND CHILDCARE ITEMS IF THEY
CHOOSE TO MAINTAIN THE LABELING
OF KIDS SECTIONS FIVE BOYS AND
GIRLS OF THIS OF COURSE HELPS
RUMORS ABOUT STIGMA AS POSSIBLE
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY- BEHIND THE
GAME TARGET AND MANY OTHER
RETAILERS ALREADY DOING THIS IN
PRACTICE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN- I ALSO WANT TO THINK
LIKE A CO AUTHOR. CRISTINA
GARCIA CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AS WELL AS MYSELF AS THE
CHAIR OF THE LGBT LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT
IS BEAUTIFUL. INSIDERS AS WELL
AS ROB SMITH WITH THE FOOD
PROJECT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU SIR WITNESSES
PLEASE PROCEED. ARE YOU THERE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MADAM VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND I WENT MY
NAME IS PRINCE GARDNER I'M NINE
AND A HALF YEARS OLD AND YOU
MAY KNOW EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY FOUR
START AT MY AGE YEAH BUT I
NEVER THOUGHT IT WOULD GET THIS
FAR. THERE ARE SO MANY YOU KNOW
KIDS OUT THERE WHO DO NOT
NECESSARILY FIT INTO SOCIETY'S
EXPECTATIONS IT CAN BE SO HARD
FOR THEM TO LOOK AT A PARTY IN
THE GIRLS SECTION OR TORY
DINOSAUR IN THE BOYS. SECTION
AND SHE ALL EYES ON THEM AND
SAY THEY'RE LOCKED INTO A
SECTION LABELED FOR THE
OPPOSITE GENDER WHEN. I AM HERE
I HAVE. THE COMPANY BUT EVERY
CASE CAN'T THAT. I CAN GET SOME
THAT YOU BEING. OUT OF. A TOOK
TWENTY SECTION LABELED FOR THE
OPPOSITE GENDER. BUT WHAT IF IT
WASN'T LIKE THAT BUT IF THE
CHINESE STARTED TEARING DOWN
THE WALLS BETWEEN X. X. AND X.
Y. AND MADE SO MANY KIDS FEEL
LIKE THEY BELONG. SO YEAH I
GUESS I'M JUST TRYING. TO MAKE
KIDS FEEL COMFORTABLE PLAYING
WITH. TOYS FROM BOTH GIRLS AND
BOYS DEPARTMENT THANK YOU.
THANK NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH EVERYBODY THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME SPEAK- SO IT'S
GREAT THAT ALL OF BRITAIN
YOU'RE AN INSPIRATION AND MORE
DOES SHE LIVE IN THE YOUNG
PEOPLE- I THINK SOMANY DRUGS
SMITH AND- STEVEN PONDER THE
FLU PROJECT WHICH IS A GENDER
FREE FASHION BRAND AS WELL AS
GET FLUID WHICH IS GENDER
EXPANSIVE TRAINING FOR
CORPORATIONS AND PRIOR TO THIS-
INITIATIVE I WAS- CHIEF PRODUCT
OFFICER BRIEFLY ABOUT THE NIKE
KIDS GLOBALLY. AND I'D ALL
VYING FOR ME SO I UNDERSTAND
THE SPACE A BIT FROM A
RETAILER'S PERSPECTIVE- YOU
MENTIONED- THAT YOU KNOW
ALREADY THAT TARGET HAS MOVED
IN THIS DIRECTION ALSO
MCALLISTER LISTEN TO THEIR
CONSUMERS BOTH PARENTS AND KIDS
AND REORGANIZE THEIR ENTIRE
AWESTRUCK SURE AROUND. SO IT
CAN. FOR J. SO THEY STARTED
MOVEMENT SO HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW
SOCIETAL EXPECTATIONS AROUND
GENDER IMPACT EACH AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US. WERE LIMITED
BY GENDER BINARY CONSTRUCTS
BOYS ARE RAISED FULL OF
AMBITION OPPORTUNITY. AND
SUCCESS- WHICH THEY TOLD WHICH
BEFORE THEY CAN PLAY WITH THEM
WHICH THEY CAN PLAY WITH A
GIRLS ARE TAUGHT TO BE
NURTURING SWEETING HIND. AND
EQUALLY AS LIMITING AND A
CHOICE SELECTION. RECENTLY I
WATCHED YOUR KIDS DEPARTMENT I
TOOK NOTES OF WHAT THE GIRLS
SECTION THAT AND IT'S SAD. WITH
T. SHIRTS FULL OF PAINTING
GLITTER SMILE STAY HAPPY FOLLOW
YOUR DREAMS. BUT ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE OF THE BOYS
DEPARTMENT WHICH IS BLUE GREEN
WITH LANGUAGE. LEGEND FUTURE
HERO WORLDWIDE VISION. SO
RETAILERS ARE HOPEFULLY WHEN I
WAKE UP ONE DAY BUT HOW MUCH
LONGER WILL CALIFORNIA KIDS
HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL THAT
HAPPENS. CHILDREN WHO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PLAY AND EXPRESS
THEMSELVES WITH THEIR OWN
CREATIVITY GROWTH TO HAVE
GREATER AWARENESS FOR THEIR
IDENTITY AND SELF ESTEEM AND
BECOME AGENTS OF GENDER.
EQUALITY I REALLY THE SKIS
SMALLING COMEDIANS FOR SOME
PEOPLE HOWEVER DECONSTRUCTING
THE SHERRY JUST THE BEGINNING.
OF UNLEASHING A YOUNG PERSON'S
FULL POTENTIAL- WE ARE CAPABLE
AND RESPONSIBLE. IT'S SPACES
YOUNG. FOR ALL P. FOR THAT
MATTER THE OPPORTUNITY TO. A
AND WITH FEAR JUDGMENT. WE'RE
GETTING. MUST BE ELIMINATED TO
ACHIEVE THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I SEE
NO SUCH WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ZERO EIGHT
FOUR I SEE NO WITNESSES THERE
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ZERO EIGHT
FOUR WE WILL PROCEED. THANK YOU
AND PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE LINE ONE
THIRTY PLEASE FIND HE TURNED TO
THE NUMBERS THIS IS TOMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA INTO COURT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. REALLY.
YEAH THAT. THE NEXT D. YEAH
THREE THREE I MEAN YOU CAN KEEP
IT WITHIN AFRICA ME JUST A
MOMENT HERE. THANK YOU. YOUR
LINE ONE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI JOSH TO CONVEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
SEND THEM FURTHER AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
BEGINNING WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
ZERO EIGHT FOUR I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR. FOLLOWING
THE SAME PROCESS IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPTED INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
ZERO EIGHT FOUR WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD WITH THOSE WITNESSES.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME OF SORROW. AND NOBODY IF
YOU CURRENTLY THANK YOU
MODERATOR LET'S NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS REGARDING
THIS MEASURE SENATOR BOOKER. I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
TAKING ON THIS ISSUE OR
QUESTION JUST BE CLEAR THIS IS
NOT BANNED GIRLS AND BOYS
SECTION BUT REQUIRES AN
ADDITIONAL. SECTIONS ARE
CORRECT. DID THEY GIVE IT TO
THE CHAIR OF IF I MIGHT SUGGEST
IS TO SET A RECORD ANSWERING
YOUR QUESTION SPECIFICALLY IT
IS NOT A BAND. ALLOWS FOR THE
PLACEMENT OF A GENDER NEUTRAL
SECTIONS OF FOOD RETAILERS
STILL DECIDES TO HAVE A BOYS
AND GIRLS SECTION THEY CAN
STILL HAVE A KIDS SECTION. A
GENDER NEUTRAL SECTION SO IT
DOES NOT BAN. THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR COLLINS ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE SOME REMEMBER LOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK MY CO
AUTHOR MISS GARCIA WHO IS THE
CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
SITES TO HELP REMOVE THE
STIGMA- WE'D HEARD FROM A
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT IS
WHY SHOULD A YOUNG GIRL GO TO
THE BOYS SECTION IF THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN DINOSAURS OR THE
PERIODIC TABLE TO MOVE AS MUCH
STIGMA AS POSSIBLE TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE AN INCLUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU SIR DO WE
HAVE A MOTION MOTION BY SENATOR
PAN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY FOUR DEEP PASSES AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ROSS.
ROSS HI ROSS I MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA BEATS NO BEATS NO
BACKER BACKER I DAUGHTER I
THOUGHT I A MAN. HER TADO JONES
LLEVA HI LEVI EYED MAN. NEWMAN
A SHOW OF BOGUS NO I SHOW ABOVE
NO PAN. HE AND I. THE VOTE IS
FIVE TO TWO WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER. PHYLUM NUMBER FOURTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SIR YOU
HAVE ONE BILL TO PRESENT TODAY
IT IS ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
ZERO TWO PLEASE PROCEED IN
READING. HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- AB THIRTEEN OH TWO
CODIFIES REGULATIONS THAT THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROLADOR
EXPECTED CANNABIS-
ADVERTISEMENT ALONG HIGHWAYS-
CIVICALLY THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
CANNABIS LICENSEES TO ADVERTISE
OR MARKET ON THE BILLBOARD
ALONG A HIGHWAY. THAT IS
FURTHER THAN A FIFTEEN MILE
RADIUS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BORDER. AS A COMEDIAN ALICE'S
POINTS OUT IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WHEN THE BUREAU ADOPTED
REGULATIONS CLARIFY PORTION THE
LANGUAGE ADOPTED IN PROP SIXTY
FOUR. WITH RESPECT TO BILLBOARD
ADVERTISEMENT. LANGUAGE IN PROP
SIXTY FOUR STATES THE LICENSEE
SHALL NOT ADVERTISE OR MARKET
ON A BILLBOARD OR SIMILAR
ADVERTISED DEVICES ON THE
INTERSTATE HIGHWAY THAT CROSSES
THE CALIFORNIA BORDER OR ON A
STATE HIGHWAY WHICH CROSSES THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER. OF COURSE NO
STATE HIGHWAY DOES CROSS THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER SO THAT'S A
VERY HARD ONE TO FIGURE OUT-
THE BUREAU CONCLUDED THAT PROP
SIXTY FOUR DOES NOT CLARIFY TO
WHAT EXTENT SUCH PROHIBITIONS
WOULD TAKE PLACE. AND FELT THAT
A FIFTEEN MILE RADIUS WAS
APPROPRIATE. UNFORTUNATELY THE
BUREAU'S REGULATIONS WERE
CHALLENGED IN THE ST LOUIS
OBISPO COURT- WHICH RULED THAT
THE BUREAU LACKED AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE REGULATIONS. MY
SUPPORTERS AND I FUNDAMENTALLY
DISAGREE ON THAT POINT
UNFORTUNATELY THE INDUSTRY DID
NOT KNOW THE COURT. CASE WAS
TAKING PLACE AND THEREFORE I
WAS NOT ABLE TO APPEAL THE
RULING- AND THE RULING WAS THAT
ANY INTERSTATE HIGHWAY THAT
CROSSES THE BORDER SUCH AS I.
EIGHTY. FOR THAT GOES TO THE
BORDER LIKE FIFTY- COULD NOT-
HAVE- BILLBOARDS- ON IT OR
ADJACENT TO IT THAT- WERE
ADVERTISING FOR CANNABIS- THE-
ON THE OTHER HND ADJACENT
HIGHWAYS IN THE BAY AREA WE
HAVE TWO EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY THEY DON'T CROSS THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER. SO ALL OF
THOSE HIGHWAYS- CAN HAVE
CANNABIS SCIENCE. SO THE
DIFFICULTY WE HAVE HERE'S
THERE'S AN ILLICIT MARKET. AND
WHAT THOSE BILLBOARDS DID WAS
IT GAVE- THE LEGAL ADVICE THE
LEGAL MARKET WAY TO ADVERTISE
THEIR LOCATION SO THAT PEOPLE
KNEW WHERE TO GO TO GET. FULLY
INSPECTED- FULLY LEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS- AND
BECAUSE OF THIS WE'RE ASKING.
THAT WE PASS A BILL WHICH WILL.
PUT BACK THE- EARLY REGULATION
THAT IT'S WITHIN FIFTY MILES OF
THE BORDER WE HAVE ASKED THE
LAW FIRM THAT WROTE UP. THE
REGULATION WHAT WAS MEANT WHEN
THEY PUT THIS IN AND NONE OF
THEM HAD ANY ARE WRECKED HAD
ANY- MEMORY AS TO WHY THAT
PARTICULAR PROVISION WAS PUT IN
OR HE WHO ASKED THAT IT BE PUT
IN. WE BELIEVE IT'S BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO BE
ADVERTISING A CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS TO STATES THAT MIGHT
NOT HAVE A LEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET. RIGHT NOW I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY TWO
WITNESSES AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. AND
DENNIS LOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING ASSOCIATION. I ALSO
HAVE RON MEALS ON THE PHONE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT HIGHWAY
ADVERTISEMENT. HE RETIRED AS
GENERAL COUNSEL FROM CALTRANS.
THANK YOU SERVICE MS JENKINS
MISTER LOPER PLEASE PROCEED.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN OKAY GO AHEAD GO HEAD
DENNIS. GOOD MORNING MR DEM
SLOGAN FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ASSOCIATION
SHE ASSOCIATES MEMBERSHIP.
INCLUDES A SMALL SMART AS
COMPANIES IN OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING AND WE REPRESENT
OVER 90% OF THE LICENSE OFFSET
SIGNS ALL OVER MEMBERS UNITED
SPORTING A P. THIRTEEN OH TWO
EVEN THOUGH THE THOSE MEMBERS
WHO DO NOT CARRY CANNABIS
LICENSE AT ALSO INTERVIEWED
VOTERS RECOGNIZE. THAT BANNING
ADVERTISING FOR LEGAL PRODUCTS
IS A THREAT TO ALL ADVERTISERS
UNDERSTATED CONTEMPLATED
APPROPRIATE RESTRICTIONS
RELATED ADVERTISING OF ENTRY
STRICTLY PRODUCTS OVER
CURRENTLY NOT A SINGLE STATE.
AS AN OUTRIGHT BAN. RELATED TO
OUR HAS OF LEGAL CANNABIS UNDER
AFRICA IS SURGICALLY CANNABIS
ADVERTISE ALL EXTRA. RESTRICTED
COMPETENCY STANDARDS INCLUDE
SONY INSIDE HI STACEY LANDSCAPE
AND SCENIC HIGHWAY FOR
PROHIBITIONS STATE REGULAR
STATE AND REGULATIONS ARE CLEAR
THAT THE ROLE THE STATE HAS
BEEN PROTECTING CHILDREN FROM
ADVERTISEMENT. THAT WOULD BE A
GOOD CURRENT ANYONE UNDER AGE
TWENTY ONE THE OPERATOR RETURNS
IN A COMPACT CANNABIS INDUSTRY
HAVE COMPILED WITH PREVIOUS
PEOPLE. HAVE COME TO LIGHT WITH
PREVIOUS BBC REGULATIONS THE
BASIC CITY HAD A DIFFICULT TASK
WHEN DRAFTING REGULATIONS TO A
MINUTE TO IMPLEMENT THE HUNDRED
PAGE PROPOSITION. AND SEEKING
THE BALLOT RIGHTS OF LICENSES
TO PLAY EARLY CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE WAS ADDED CREATING THE
FIFTY MILE BUFFER WITHOUT THE
CLARIFICATION LICENSEE WITH.
BUSINESS LOCATED NEAR THE FOUR
FIVE COULD ADVERTISE THE ONE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. BUSINESS
THERE ARE QUITE A GOOD BOX
INSIDE FIVE REGIONS FROM OREGON
TO ALL THE WAY TO THE MEXICAN
BORDER. ADDITIONALLY THE STAGE
ALL NEIGHBORING STATES OF LEGAL
AT THIS TIME TERRY STAYED EIGHT
ALL NEIGHBORING STATES HAVE
LEGALIZED HOURS OF CONCERNS
RELATED TO. ANIMAL IS TURNED ON
CANNABIS TURNER TURNED OUT
TERRORISM. AT BORDER CROSSINGS
HAS REDUCED. ABC THIRTEEN.
TOTAL SO THE CORE CONCERN. THAT
THE REGULAR AND- WITH THIS.
THANK THE RING. REGULAR WAS NOT
BY THE OUTDOOR. INDUSTRY ON
COST GROUNDS BUT THIS ONE.
LET'S COURTS CORRECTIONS. IS
LEFT WITH AN IMPOSSIBLE STATUE
COUPLE CAUSE FRUSTRATION TO
BOTH ADVOCATES AND OPPONENTS TO
CAMPUS FREE SPEECH. IT HAS RUN
THE WHO'S FROM. OUR INDUSTRY
FOR FORTY YEARS AND ALSO IS A
RETIRED CAL ARE COUNCIL
COLTRANE'S. THANK YOU MS
JENKINS. YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IN THE TANK AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS OUT WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION FOR OUR INDUSTRY- I
WILL JUST GO AHEAD AND INDICATE
THAT THE COMMENTS PREVIOUSLY
STATED- WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE ABSENCE OF
LEGISLATION IN OUR ABILITY TO
ADVERTISE IT REALLY HINDERS ONE
OF THE ONLY PATH LEADS FOR
LEGAL CANNABIS OPERATORS TO
ADVERTISE THEIR BUSINESSES.
ONLY THIRTEEN REALLY TO
UNDERMINE COMPLIANCE AND
STRENGTHEN THE ONLINE MARKET
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE LIBEL REGULATIONS
DEALING WITH BILLBOARD CANNABIS
ADVERTISING IN THE NATION AND
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED NO OTHER
LEGALIZED STATES AND CANADA
BILLBOARD ADVERTISING FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
REQUEST YOUR I. VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S NOT
TURN TO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY. YOU KNOW WHAT
IT IS THERE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN ZERO TWO
SEEING NO WITNESSES THEY'RE
TURNING TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL. THIRTEEN ZERO
TWO WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF
SO PLEASE ONE AND ZERO THIS
TIME. ADVERTISED FOR BIDS AS
ONLY. UNDER MY COMPLAINT.
ONLINE MARKETING LINE WHEN CAME.
YES MORNING MY NAME IS DEREK
AND FOUND AND CEO OF NAPA TO ME
A LITTLE. DISPENSER AND
CULTIVATION OPERATIONS IN NAPA
SONOMA AND LAKE COUNTIES TO
PURSUE SEVERAL BRANDS I'M A
MEMBER OF THE LEGAL CANNABIS
FOR CONSUMER SAFETY COALITION
I'M PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF OUR
LOADS COALITION A LICENSED
CANNABIS BUSINESSES
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS TAX
MARIJUANA ONE APOLOGY PROJECT
SURELY AND FIFTY FIVE OTHER
BUSINESSES ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OH TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ALL ALL
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RESEARCHER
MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CMG KHALIFA THE LARGEST
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED CANNABIS
COMPANY IN THE BUSINESS-
OPERATING OUT OF SANTA CLARA
SAN MATEO COUNTIES- URGING YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RADIATE AIRLINE. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RECORD UP
WITH THIS VICTORY OF THE
REQUEST- WE ARE RUNNING OUT.
I'M HAVING DIFFICULTY HEARING
WITH THE FOLKS ON THE LINE
MODERATORS SO COULD WE-
STRAIGHTEN THAT OUT. PLEASE.
ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IF YOU'RE A MEMBER. MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF C. THE LARGEST BIRD
INTEGRATED CANNABIS IN BUSINESS
OPERATING OUT OF ONE MOMENT
HERE. YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU I WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD FROM MR MARTIN.
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN-
IT'S FREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GREAT. IT WOULD BE RECALLED
THAT. I I'M HAVING DIFFICULTY
HEARING. MODERATORS SO QUICKLY.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A MOMENT AND STRAIGHTEN OUT OUR
AUDIO VISUAL. SITUATION HERE.
MADAME MODERATOR ARE YOU ABLE
TO HEAR ME. I'M HEARING YOU I
DO WE HAVE WHAT LINE ONE FIFTY
SIX OPEN HERE. OKAY GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT HERE THANK YOU.
WELL- MODERATOR ARE WE READY TO
PROCEED.
MODERATOR THIS IS MIKE
CHECK CAN YOU HEAR ME. EACH.
TESTING. ONE TWO THREE. SHE SHE.
BETTER MODERATOR. ARE YOU ABLE
TO HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
CLEARLY SHOULD RESUME THE A
PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION LET'S
RESUME WERE AKING SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE NEXT IN ORDER PLEASE HAVE
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING PAM LOPEZ WITH K. THREE
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH TWO. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT ON THE
LINE THIRTY THREE THREE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
YOU'RE HARRY SUBMERGING HERE
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND A
FOURTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS ARE
CHAMBER STRONGLY SUPPORTS
EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE AT ONE FORTY
NINE ONE FOUR NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GERRY
BASKET TO SAN DIEGO CHAPTER OF
AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS.
REPRESENTING THREE THOUSAND
MEMBERS. R. S. A. B. THIRTEEN
NO KILL THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY THREE
FIVE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL GOOD MORNING THIS IS EDWIN
LOMBARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A. B. THIRTEEN OH
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
THIRTEEN ONE ONE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHURCH
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CLINT
OLIVIER ARE REPRESENTING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUSINESS
FEDERATION AND A COALITION OF
BUSINESS GROUPS ACROSS THE
STATE SUPPORTING THIS BILL WE
ALONG WITH THE LOS ANGELES
BUSINESS FEDERATION SAN
FRANCISCO CHAMBER AND EIGHT
OTHER BUSINESS GROUPS. STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB. THIRTEEN OH TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
INABILITY LINE AT ONE FOURTEEN
ONE ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES YES MY NAME IS
MICHAEL COHEN AND WITH. WITH
WITH THE PROPERTY VERY
DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE SUPPORT WE
SUPPORT- THIRTEEN OH TO ADD
HERE THAT IS IT IS. ALL
REASONABLE AND SENSIBLE
POLICIES REGULATIONS THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
ONE FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING WHEN I THINK ABOUT
CHRISTIANITY ON BEHALF OF LAMAR
ADVERTISING MEADOW AT YOUR
ADVERTISING AND GENERAL OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING IN SUPPORT AND.
EIGHTY ONE THREE ZERO TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. AND
WITH ONLINE AT ONE FIFTY SEVEN
ONE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BINDER CANYON REPRESENTING KGB
RESERVE A SOCIAL EQUITY AND
LIKE NEXT CANNABIS BRAND BASED
OUT OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
ADVERTISING THEIR PRODUCTS TO
ADULTS IS CURRENTLY VERY
DIFFICULT YOU CANNOT USE.
MICHAEL COHEN AND EDWARD.
EXCUSE ME REMEMBER. FOR THOSE
ON THE LINE NAME AFFILIATION
AND ACTION ON THAT PLEASE. YOUR
DEVICE. AND AS A REMINDER FOR
ANY OF THE WITNESSES ON THE
LINE PLEASE MUTE YOUR LINE IF
YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING OUR NEXT
LITTLE LINE ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY WHAT THE
POLICY REPRESENTING DRUG. WHAT
COULD BE MINORITY AND WOMEN
OWNED. IN TERMS. IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT YOU CANNOT USE A
DIGITAL OR OTHER TRADITIONAL
FORMS OF MARKETING WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN OH TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
REMEMBER NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY NEXT WITNESS. ONE
ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS GET YOU IN
THERE THAT I REPRESENT THE
SPECIAL BRANCH L. EDTA. ABOUT
DYING AND THE CALLS WILL BE
EQUITY TRADE CERTIFICATION
GROUP AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
H. B. THANKS SIR NEXT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY ONE
FOUR ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO LINE ONE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN HELLO PLEASE YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD SIR WE ARE DOING A
VERY PRESIDENT AND CEO
CALIFORNIA SENATE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE SIXTY ONE ONE SIX
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT
PLEASE HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS DAVID GOLDMAN GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
REPRESENT THE PRIMARY
DEMOCRATIC UP TO SAN FRANCISCO
FOR CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF BABY THIRTEEN OH TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY ONE
SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT
PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE A ONE
FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS MADISON
SHOCKLEY. SOCIAL EQUITY- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR MEMBER OF THE
SOCIAL EQUITY HOLDERS AND
WORKERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
STRONGLY IN FAVOR HE B.
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE ONE THREE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CARE MEMBERS REALLY
SANCHEZ WITH MILLER SUSPECTS
AND ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
WEEDMAPS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE FIFTY SIX ONE FIVE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I ONE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT PLEASE. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE AT ONE SIX THREE ONE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAITLIN
O'NEILL ON BEHALF OF YOU'RE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. AND WE HAVE A NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE LYNN.
SILVER ON THE LINEA SENIOR
ADVISER FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE MS SILVER. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ROB SENATORS GOOD
MORNING I AM A DOCTOR WHEN
SOBER PEDIATRICIANS CLINICAL
PROFESSOR AT UCSF AND SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE. AFTER ALMOST FORTY
YEARS WORKING TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM HARMFUL
PRODUCTS IT IS TERRIBLY SAD TO
SEE OUR HARD EARNED LESSONS
FROM THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY'S
WORKED WITH DICK GENERATIONS OF
USE SO EASILY FORGOTTEN.
BLANKETING HIGHWAYS WITH ADS
FOR CANNABIS IS BAD PUBLIC
POLICY WHAT OTHER LOCATIONS CAN
AT LEAST TARGETED AUDIENCES
THAT IS NOT POSSIBLE TO BUILD
FORGE LEGAL INDUSTRY CAN
OPERATE WELL AND PROFITABLY
WITHOUT BILLBOARDS FINDING A
BUSINESS FROM A LEGAL BUSINESS
ON WEEDMAPS IS AS EASY AS CAN
BE. AND OTHER STATES DO HAVE A
VARIETY OF ADVERTISING
RESTRICTIONS ALLOWING CANNABIS
BILLBOARDS ON OUR HIGHWAYS
BREAKS PROMISES MADE TO THE
VOTERS IN PROP SIXTY FOUR THAT
WE WOULD HAVE THE NATION'S
STRICTEST CHILD PROTECTIONS
INCLUDING AD RESTRICTIONS. AND
A HIGHWAY BILLBOARD BAN.
CANADA'S CAN BROKE FREE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN UNDER THOSE
PROJECTS. THIS LED TO ME BAD.
ON CALIFORNIA HIGHWAYS EXPOSING
MILLIONS OF CHILDREN DAILY ON
THEIR WAY TO SCHOOL. AND WE
SUCCESSFUL PARENTS SUED AND THE
COURT FOUND THE REGULATION TO
CONFLICT WITH STATE LAW IN
OCTOBER. BILL WILL SHAMELESSLY
EXPOSE OUR KIDS AGAIN. IT TOOK
DECADES AND LAWSUITS FOR THE
TOBACCO MASTER SETTLEMENT TO
GET JOE CAMEL THAT WE GREW UP
WITH OFFER HIGHLY. WHY
LEGISLATE TO BRING BACK HIS
CANNABIS COUSIN AND EXPOSE OUR
GRANDCHILDREN. WHAT PURPOSE IS
SERVED I DIDN'T MAXIMIZING
PROFITS. SURE THIS IS A
DIFFERENT KIND OF. POLICY
SHOULD REPORT THE LEGAL ACCESS
BUT NOT MAXIMIZE GROWTH AT ANY
COST. OUTDOOR ADVERTISING
INCREASES YOU INTEREST IN USE
AND POSITIVE. PERCEPTIONS OF
HARMFUL PRODUCTS. EVEN JOHN
TALKED IN YOUR PEACE HE IS
FIFTEEN TO YEAR OLDS IN FIVE
STATES INCLUDING OURS FOUND
THAT EXPOSURE TO CANNABIS
BILLBOARDS HAD A STRONG
INSIGNIFICANT RELATIONSHIP. TO
FREQUENT USE AND ADDICTION WHAT
FACEBOOK OR INSTAGRAM ADS DID
NOT TO THE SAME EXTENT. TO
SOLVE BILLBOARDS EVEN ONLY
OCCASIONALLY AT FIVE TIMES THE
OTHER DEVELOPING CANNABIS USE
DISORDER OF THOSE WHO NEVER SAW
THAT. THOSE WHO SAW THEM
FREQUENTLY HAD SIX TIMES THE
ODDS THAT CANNABIS USE DISORDER
IN SEVEN TIMES FOR FREQUENT
USE. IN OREGONBY ONE YEAR
AFTER LEGALIZATION THREE
QUARTERS OF EIGHTH GRADERS
REPORTED SEEING MARIJUANA ADS
PRIMARILY BILLBOARDS
STOREFRONTS. AND ONLINE IN THE
PAST MONTH. THANK YOU FOR TELL
FOR TWELVE SEVEN YEAR OLD
THROWS. BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY NINETEEN. ARE UNWISE
TO YOUR BILLBOARD FINISH ALMOST
CERTAINLY CONTRIBUTED. AND
HISTORICALLY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS OF COLOR ARE THE MOST
EXPOSED TO BILLBOARD AD FOR
HERBAL PRODUCTS. WHAT WILL BE
ACHIEVED BY A B. THIRTEEN OH
TWO IS MORE HEAVY USE MORE
DEPENDABLE KIDS. MORE KIDS
DROPPING OUT OR DEVELOPING
PSYCHOSIS FROM DABBING WE'RE
GETTING IN CAR ACCIDENTS I AM
CONFIDENT THAT THAT IS NOT WHAT
THE SENATE WANTS. FOR ARGUES WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU HOLD
TRUE TO CALIFORNIA VOTERS
PROTECT OUR KIDS AND BOTH MADE
ON A. B. THIRTEEN OH TWO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR LET'S TURN
TO. IN UPPER IN THE I SEE NO
WITNESSES IDENTIFYING
THEMSELVES. WHETHER ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN ZERO TWO. SEEING NONE.
LET'S MOVE THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE PROMPT ANY WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN ZERO TWO WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD WITH THOSE WITNESSES.
THE GENTLEMAN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT OPPOSITION THE TWO
THIRTEEN ZERO TWO THE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. FIRST WE
GO TO LINE. SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SENATORS THIS IS
ADEQUATE- CALLING IN ON BEHALF
OF CONCERNED PARENTS OF
CALIFORNIA CPC WE ARE JOINED BY
MENTAL HEALTH ASSOCIATIONS AND
CHILDREN ADVOCACY GROUPS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN OH TWO AND
ASK YOU PLEASE AND BE HALF OF
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS ABOUT
NAY ON THIS BILL. PHILBRICK
ABILITY INTO AND OUT OF THERE
UNAVOIDABLE COMMERCIALS THIS
FACT THOSE DRIVING IN CARS
THOSE WALKING DOWN THE STREET.
AND THOSE WHO. HI SOMETIMES
UNWILLING TRAVELERS IN CARS
LIKE CHILDREN ARE. LARGE AND IN
THE FACES OF OUR CHILDREN OUR
CHILDREN EXPERIENCING MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS AS WELL AS OTHER
TYPES OF HEALTH CORRECT
PRACTICES ASSOCIATED WITH.
MARIJUANA AND DO NOT NEED
ANYMORE- GET AFTERNOON RICK
MA'AM REMEMBER I'M PRETTY
TOLERANT BUT THE RULES HERE
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
THANK YOU. OKAY I'M SO SORRY
NEXT PLEASE THE LINE OF ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
PERFECTLY PLEASE PROCEED. HOW
GREAT I DO NOT I NEEDED I
NEEDED- MIGHT MY NAME IS CAROL
GREEN I AM SPEAKING AS A PARENT
VOLUNTEER AND ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY CHILDREN
INCLUDING MY SON. DIED AFTER
EXPERIENCING AFFECT OKAY. AND
BELIEVING THE BILLBOARDS THAT
HE THOUGHT. THANK YOU I'M SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS NEXT PLEASE. WE
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PERFECTLY
PLEASE PROCEED. SORRY THERE'S
AN ECHO MADELINE COOPER FROM
THE OFTEN WORK ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR FOSTER COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
PLEASE REMEMBER PLEASE MUTE
YOUR DEVICES NEXT PLEASE.
MEXICO TO FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DR DRUMMING
CONSIDERATION OF THE LACK OF
SIMILAR ABILITY TO ADVERTISED
BY THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY. THE
UNITED NATIONS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY NOT
A LOT ADVERTISEMENT. AND FONDLY
OPPOSED THE BALANCE OF THE
STANDING ME UP WITH THE
DIFFERENT MENTAL HEALTH
IMPAIRING SUBSTANCE BY OPPOSED
PAID. WHAT THREE OIL. THANK YOU.
HI THIS IS THE ROOM ONE OF
THOSE ON THE LINE NOT TO ABUSE
THIS PROCESS I'VE ASKED FOR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL NEXT PLEASE. MEXICO
TO LINE UP ONE SIXTY TWO
BECAUSE I HAD. HI MY RELATIVES
WOULD COME TO TALK TO HELP. OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO ONE AGAIN THANK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
NEXT PLEASE. THANKS TO THE TWO
NIN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CLUED ON TO LINE
THE ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVEN NEXT PLEASE PLEASE
PROCEED. THE NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
PERFECTLY PLEASE PROCEED NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE. MY NAME IS KEY TO
KEEPING I AM A MOTHER OF THREE
AND REPRESENTED SOCIAL EQUITY
MARKETS AFFECTING UNIT AND I
MISSED MY OPPORTUNITY REPORT
BUT I AM IN SUPPORT AT THE ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WE
GO TO LINE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINETY NINE ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS BARBARA
GORDON I'M A PUBLIC HEALTH
EDUCATOR AND YOUTH MENTOR
PROJECT DIRECTORS WRONGLY
OPPOSED THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. I
NEXT TO THE TREE LINE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JOE EVER SIGN I AM THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY MARIJUANA
PREVENTION INITIATIVES THAT ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
THIRTEEN OKAY. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE ONE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
PLEASE PROCEED AFTER LUNCH THE
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE. FINAL
CHARMED SENATORS MY NAME IS
ZAHRA FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO I AM
ONE OF THE TRAINEES REPRESENTED
MATTHEW FARMERS CHALLENGE THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL IS
REGULATION- PRESENT MANY
PARENTS ON THE CENTRAL COAST
WHO WANT CHILDREN'S HEALTH BUT
BEFORE CORPORATE PROFITS AND
POSE AT. ONE THREE OH TWO
PLEASE VOTE NOW THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANKS TO THE
TO LINE ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS OURS
YOU CAN SEARCH ON THE POLICY
RESEARCH ASSOCIATE AT THE PUMP
INSTITUTE- COMING IN OPPOSITION
TO IF YOU WANT TO THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
NEXT PLEASE. MEXICO TO LINE UP
ONE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS JIM
KENNEDY I'M WITH YOU TOWARD
EUROPE POLICY MONETISATION
WORKING ON THAT TO SUPPORT THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN AND YOUNG PEOPLE YEAH
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE. AN EXCELLENT LINE AT
ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN-
SENATORS MY NAME IS STUART
JENKINS I'M ONE OF THE OTHER
PUBLIC INTEREST ATTORNEYS HAVE
REPRESENTED MATTHEW FARMER
AGAINST THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL IN SAN LUIS OBISPO- I
AM REPRESENT MANY. PEOPLE AND
PARENTS IN SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY TO OPPOSE THE PLACEMENT
OF BILLBOARDS FOR INSTANCE IN
OUR CASE THERE WERE YOUNG GIRLS
ON SURFBOARDS COMING UP THROUGH
THE OCEAN THAT LOOK LIKE THEY
WERE FIFTEEN- WHICH ADVERTISES
THIS PRODUCT TO CHILDREN. ALONG
OUR HIGHWAYS WE NEED TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM A PRODUCT THAT
DELIVERS 50% MORE CARCINOGENS
AND 75% MORE OF ANOTHER
CARCINOGEN MEN'S BACKUP. SO
PLEASE VOTE NO ONE THIRTEEN OH
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
REMEMBER THE ROLE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL NEXT PLEASE. HE THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE ONE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME PERFECTLY PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATIE
STRANG EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH
THE SAN MARCOS DRUG PREVENTION
COALITION IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT NEXT PLEASE. MEXICO TO
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
SAID THIS- RAMEN COURT OF
MOSCOW COACH HERE FOR DRUG
SAFETY SOLANO CALLING IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE.
CONNECT TO THE TO LINE A ONE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
HI MY NAME'S TERRY BEARS AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF- BLOOM
FARMS WERE LICENSED CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTOR I MISSED MY
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT- BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT-
AB THIRTEEN OKAY. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT PLEASE. MEXICO TO LINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NEXT PLEASE REMAIN ON
THE LINE ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS KELLY
MCCORMICK I'M APPEARANCE AND I
RUN A YOUTH MENTORING PROGRAM I
AM OPPOSED TO ABC THIRTEEN OH
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT PLEASE. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS REGARDING
THIS MEASURE. SEEING NONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES- WITH REGARD
TO THE STUDY THAT WAS MENTIONED
BY THE OPPOSITION REPORTING OUT
THE CORRELATION IS NOT THE SAME
AS CAUSATION. OF BILLBOARDS
TEND TO BE AND URBAN AREAS
WHICH-HAVE GREATER- CANNABIS
USED TO BEGIN WITH ALSO POINT
OUT THAT THESE BILLBOARDS
CANNOT LEGALLY HAVE ANYONE
UNDER TWENTY ONE ON THE ON THE
BILLBOARD. OR ANYTHING THAT
WOULD APPEAL TO CHILDREN
FURTHERMORE THEY HAVE TO BE IN
AN AREA WHERE 70% OF THE PEOPLE
SEEN THEM ARE OVER AGE TWENTY
ONE- I BELIEVE THERE ARE
ADEQUATE- PROTECTIONS LOG IN I
WILL ALSO POINT OUT AS A FATHER
OF TWO THAT FRANKLY MY SON WAS
INTRODUCED TO CANNABIS AND WHEN
IT WAS TOTALLY ILLEGAL IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL- MY DAUGHTER IN
HIGH SCHOOL THE KIDS KNOW ABOUT
CANNABIS IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
BECAUSE OF A BILLBOARD THAT
THEY DECIDE TO GO WITH THIS
BILLBOARD IS GOOD FOR. HIS
ADVERTISING WHERE THE LOCATIONS
ARE FOR THE LEGAL MARKET SO
THAT PEOPLE DON'T. SUPPORT THE
ILLEGAL MARKET WHICH IS THE
MARKET THAT SELLS TO CHILDREN.
SO I'M ASKING YOU. LET'S GET
RID OF THE ILLEGAL MARKET.
LET'S PROTECT BLACKS PROTECTED
INDUSTRY WHICH IS GOING TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR MAY I HAVE A
MOTION ON ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN ZERO TWO. SENATOR DODD
HAS MOVED THE BILL THANK YOU
CENTER LABOR. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB THIRTEEN OR TWO DO
YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
ROTH. ROTH IRA MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. BABIES BECKER
DAUGHTER. DOT I EXAMINE HER
TADO. JONES LLEVA LEAVE THE ICE
MAN MAIN HI NEWMAN. A SHOW A
BOGUS. HAN. THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES WE HAVE MANY MANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MISSING WE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK THANK
YOU SENATOR. THE NEXT ITEM WE
WILL TAKE A C. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
SOLACE. WHO'S BEEN HERE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME SIR WE WILL
TAKE UP YOUR ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ZERO SEVEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH
SEVEN WHICH EXPANDS AND
IMPROVES THE TEMPORARY
LICENSURE PROGRAM FOR SPOUSES
OF ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY-
SERVICEMEMBERS MILITARY SPOUSES
ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO BE
UNEMPLOYED AND UNDER EMPLOYED
WHEN MOVING TO A NEW STATE-
THERE ARE MILITARY SPOUSES WHO
HAVE TO WAIT MONTHS TO RECEIVE
A LICENSE THAT THEY'RE FULLY
QUALIFIED FOR. MEANWHILE THEY
LOSE OUT ON POTENTIAL INCOME
AND ARE UNABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE WAY THEY
DESERVE NOT ONLY IS GOOD FOR
MILITARY SPOUSES IT'S GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY- THE
MILITARY NATIONAL SECURITY
ACTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA
GENERATED ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
BEGINNING THIS YEAR THE
MILITARY SERVICES ARE NOW
REQUIRED TO INCLUDE MILITARY
SPOUSE PORTABILITY AND
EMPLOYMENT IN THEIR MISSION.
BASING DECISIONS THIS MEANS
APARTMENT OF DEFENSES CRITERIA
FOR LICENSURE PORTABILITY. AND
IT'S A WIN WIN FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES AND STAYED IN THE
PUBLIC. I DO HAVE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR I HVE-
TODAY TESTIFYING KELLY MAY
DOUGLAS. WHO IS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE THE
PACIFIC SOUTHWEST REGIONAL
LIAISON AND ALSO STEPHEN MOORE
WHO IS THE SPOUSE OF AN ACTIVE
DUTY SERVICEMEMBERS STATIONED
AT TRAVIS AIR FORCE BASE. THANK
YOU MS DOUGLAS MISS TOMORROW
PLEASE PROCEED IN ORDER. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ROB
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KELLY MAY HAVE LEFT AND
I'M WITH THE DEPARTMENT DEFENSE
I THINK WE'VE GOT OFFICE I'M
HERE TO GET STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE POLICY CHANGES PROPOSED
AGAIN EIGHTY ONE AT THAT IN. A
TOP PRIORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE TO HELP MILITARY
SPOUSES WITH CAREER PORTABILITY
OVER THERE IN THE MILITARY IN
THE WORKFORCE REQUIRE
PROFESSIONAL LIFE INSURANCE
EITHER EIGHT. I AM AT THE
OFFICE VERY LIFE INSURER OPT IN
BUTTON DOWN UNDERNEATH AND TIME
CONSUMING THE END RESULT IS
THAT NOT VERY FAST AT THE
EXPERIENCE UNDER EMPLOYMENT AND
UNEMPLOYMENT AT MUCH HIGHER
RATES THAN THEIR CIVILIAN
COUNTERPARTS. OTHER THAN THE
NUMBERS OUT. LOUD JUST
MENTIONED. ALSO IF YOU CAN'T
GET IN CALIFORNIA AS STATE HOME
TO LARGEST. OF NON FOUND WITHIN
THE NEW. I MADE MY- MANY COME
ACROSS THE- AFTER. SHOWING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. AS A RESULT OF
ACTIVE BARRIERS CAUSED BY AN-
WITH THE FROM LIFE TO JERRY HI.
MILITARY THOUGHT THEY'RE NOT TO
TAKE YOUR- HOW WHILE STOP THEIR
SPEECH HERE. EVERYTHING IT
COULD BE PUT INTO THIS.
BUSINESS OF CHOOSING. SERVING
OUR COUNTRY OR IN THE ECONOMIC
NEEDS OF THEIR FAMILY AND.
DECIDE TO LEAVE THE SERVICE. WE
BROADER ON WEEKENDS ISSUE. BACK
IN UNDERMINE PERSONAL NUMBERS
AND ALL. OUR NATION. DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED A COMMON PICTURE.
PROVIDED WITH AN EIGHTY ONE OH
SEVEN BUILDING OFF OF PREVIOUS
AFRICAN EXPANDING A SUCCESSFUL.
EXISTING TEMPORARY LICENSE OR
CAR PROGRAM IS SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD SUPPORT
MILITARY COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR. TIME AND I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU MA'AM MR MORROW.
GOOD AFTEROON SENATOR ROBB IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS STEPHEN MORROW AND I'M
A LICENSED MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST IN CALIFORNIA AND
OHIO. THOUSANDS IN ACTIVE DUTY
AIRFORCE OFFICER I AM IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE OF SEVEN
FOR MULTIPLE REASONS. I
GRADUATED FROM LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY WITH A MASTERS IN
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPY AND
ACCREDITED SCHOOL LISTED IN
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE FOUR NINE
EIGHT ZERO POINT THREE SIX-
CALIFORNIA B. B. S. I COMPLETED
MY REQUIRED COURSEWORK IN THREE
THOUSAND CLINICAL HOURS AS
SPECIFIED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES. I
PASS STEP ONE STATE BOARD THE
BLIND THAT EXTRA CALIFORNIA IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN.
SHORTLY AFTER MY SPOUSE
RECEIVED ORDERS TO RELOCATE TO
WRIGHT PATTERSON AIR FORCE BASE
IN OHIO REQUIRE YOU TO CHANGE
COURSE STOP STUDYING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL EXAMINATION
AND BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
STUDYING FOR THE NATIONAL
AMNESTY LICENSURE EXAM. I THEN
PASSED THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. I RECEIVED MY
NATIONAL LICENSE HE BEGAN
PRACTICING AFTER. THREE MONTHS
OF JOB SEARCHING IN OHIO. NINE
MONTHS MY STYLE SO HEAT OR TO
GET. YOU JUST LICENSING AND
REQUIREMENTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF BEHAVIORALSCIENCES.
MY NATIONAL LICENSE IS NOT
VALID IN CALIFORNIA. I NEEDED
TO BEGIN SETTING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. CLINICAL EXAM.
DURING THE FIVE MONTH PROCESS
THE STUDY THAT THE EXAM ON MY
FIRST ATTEMPT AND SECURE A
POSITION USING MY CALIFORNIA
LICENSE. PERSONALLY I WATCHED
APPROXIMATELY. TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
IN NET SALARY- SPOUSE DID NOT
CHOOSE APPROVE THEIR
PROFESSIONAL CAREER EVERY THREE
TO FOUR YEARS BECAUSE IT'S
BENEFICIAL. THE MILITARY SPOUSE
CHOOSES TO APPROVE THEIR
PROFESSIONAL CAREER BECAUSE OF
THEIR COMMITMENT TO THEIR
SPOUSE. AND THEIR SPOUSES COME
INTO OUR COUNTRY. EIGHTY ONE
ZERO SEVEN WILL PREVENT
MILITARY SPOUSES FROM LOSING
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN SALARY
LOST TIME IN JOB SEARCHING AND
EASE STRESSFUL TRANSITION
PROCEDURE PROFESSIONALS THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS LET'S NOT
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AND SUPPORT. I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
ZERO SEVEN. SEEING NONE LET'S
TURN TO THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY. BILL ONE ZERO
SEVEN WE WILL BEGIN. DAVID I'M
IF YOU LIKE TO COME IN SUPPORT
OF THE B. ONE OH SEVEN. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS PRISCILLA KEEP US
ON BEHALF OF THE YUBA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
TO BE JUST A MOMENT. MEXICO
CLIMBED FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MRS KERR SMILE
WITH THE NAVY ON BEHALF OF THE
ARMY MARINE CORPS NAVY AND AIR
FORCE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT AND
THANKFUL TO THE OTHER COURSE
WORK IN ADDITION. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT PLEASE. YEAH MEXICO TO
LINE AT ONE OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
YUBA COUNTY SUPERVISOR GARY
BRADFORD AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY TO REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY ONE OF SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE. NEXEO TO LINE AT ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FRANCIS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE DEAL MILITARY LIAISON
COUNCIL WE STRONGLY SUPPORT A
B. ONE OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
BY THE TIME THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS IN QUEUE. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES FIRST IN
THE GALLERY. I SEE NO WITNESSES
THERE NEXT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
I SEE KNEW WHAT NO WITNESSES
THEY'RE MOVING TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD ONCE
AGAIN PROMPTING INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
ZERO SEVEN WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THEM. IF YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF A B. ONE ZERO
SEVEN. THE MINUTE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE JUST
A MOMENT WE DO HAVE BECOME A
COMMON.
WE GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR RONALD
PRICE JR MELINDA THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHERRY STERN
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY
AND AUDIOLOGY AND HEARING AID
DISPENSERS BOARD. THE BOARD OF
THE DOCUMENT LEFT AND THEN IT
PHYSICIAN ON AB ONE OF SEVEN OF
THE PORT THE PORT FOR MILITARY
VETERANS AND SPOUSES WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS COULD WORK IN
CALIFORNIA FOR TWELVE MONTHS
WITHOUT READING THE STATE
LICENSING QUALIFICATIONS. OR
PASSING THE REQUIRED WRITTEN
AND PRACTICAL. EXAMINATIONS FOR
HEARING AID DISPENSING. HIS
EXAMINE ARE. TO ENSURE MINIMUM
COMPETENCY SIXTY FOUR PERFORM
HEARING TESTS AND FITTING FOR
HEARING AIDS WITHOUT DAMAGING
CONSUMERS HERE'S OR HEARING.
THE BOARD SEEKING AMENDMENT TO
RESTORE LANGUAGE IN THE CURRENT
LAW THAT WILL MAKE A TEMPORARY
LIFE EXPIRE UPON DENIAL OF THE
APPLICATION FOR EXPEDITED
LICENSURE BY THE BOARD. THE MAN
THAT WILL ALLOW THE BOARD TO
RETAIN IF ACCORDING TO REVOKE A
TEMPORARY LICENSE IF THE
APPLICANT IS FOUND NOT MEET THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR LICENSURE.
IN CALIFORNIA OR THE CASE
HEARING AID DISPENSERS NOT
PASSING THE REQUIRED
EXAMINATION WITHIN TWELVE
MONTHS OF THE TEMPORARY
LICENSE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
YOUR- LISTENING TO OUR COUNTRY.
THANK YOU NEXT FOR. THE NEXT TO
GO TO NINE NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS ROSE VAN
HELMS CALLING FROM ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES REPORTED TAKEN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON
EIGHTY ONE OH SEVEN ON THE
BOARD STRONGLY SUPPORTS EFFORTS
TO ASSIST MILITARY SPOUSES- BUT
IT HAS REQUESTED TO BE REMOVED
FROM THE PRESIDENT'S BILL
SPECIFICALLY DUE TO SOME
CURRENT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TEMPORARY LICENSE. AND BY
PASSING SOME LICENSING
COURSEWORK REQUIREMENTS THAT
WOULD ENSURE THE BOARD FLIGHT
SERVICE ARE PREPARED TO
PRACTICING CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE
DIVERSE ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER-
CALLING CITY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
AND CONCERNS BEFORE I CALL ON
ANYONE I SEE A COUPLE. LET ME
JUST NOTE OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A
FEW DETAILS TO WORK OUT. WITH
THE AUTHOR WITH REGARD TO OUR
VARIOUS BOARDS AND BUREAUS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR- AND- IN THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE IN
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IF
WE GET THAT FOR. A TO WORK
THOSE DETAILS OUT SO FIRST
CENTER DONE. YES THANK YOU MR-
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS. BILL FORWARD
TODAY. I CONSTANTLY GET
CHALLENGED IN QUESTION- AT THE
TRAVIS AIR FORCE BASE- HAT I
REPRESENT IN MY DISTRICT HE
BRINGS THIS ISSUE UP. TIME AND
TIME AGAIN AS A MAJOR OBSTACLE-
FOR BRINGING. BRINGING OFFICERS
IN FOR EXAMPLE OR CREATED
LISTED MAN IT. ISN'T TO
TRANSFER NTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MAKE IT ABOVE THE-
INCREDIBLY HARD. FOR THEIR
SPOUSES TO- BECOME LICENSE SO I
APPRECIATE THE WAY THIS IS
GOING I'D- ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR
TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR AND I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR- SENATOR JONES
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND SOME
MEMBERS ALICE THANKS AGAIN
AGAIN. I KNOW THIS IS. TRIED
MULTIPLE YEARS- APPLAUD YOUR
EFFORTS I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR. AND AS
ARE IN A REPRESENTATIVE OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY THAT YOU KNOW THE
LARGEST AND DOES- LARGEST.
MILITARY COMPLEX I THINK IN THE
WORLD- I KNOW A LOT OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AND ALL OF- SAN
DIEGO MILITARY BECAUSE TEACHERS
ARE GONNA BE APPRECIATIVE OF
THIS WHEN IT PASSES AND- AND
FINALLY GETS SIGNED IT. SIGNED
INTO LAW SO IF YOUCAN ADD ME
ON AS A CO AUTHOR APPRECIATED
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
JOHN CENTER PENN. I THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH- AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR- BRING
THIS FORWARD AND- BE SURE THAT
WE ADDRESS NOT ONLY OF COURSE
THE SACRIFICES OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS TO. PROTECT OUR COUNTRY
BUT THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AS
WELL WHO ARE SUPPORTING THEM. I
DIDN'T HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND I KNOW THIS IS
THE ON GOING WORK SO I GUESS
ONE IS THE HOW IS THERE A TIME
LIMIT ON HOW LONG THIS
TEMPORARY- LICENSE WILL BE IN
PLACE- BECAUSE I THINK IN THE
END WE WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE FULL
LICENSES- AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION IS. THERE'S OF. THAT
WHILE THE TEMPER LICENSES THEY
ARE YOU KNOW EXPEDITIOUSLY ON
THEIR PART- PURSUING-
FULFILLING THE REQUIREMENTS OF
A FULL LICENSE SO THAT. WAS
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND. THE
DESIRE TO BE ABLE TO GIVE
PEOPLE A QUICKER PATHWAY SO
THEY CAN. RESUME PRACTICE AND
EARN A LIVING HERE IN CITY
CALIFORNIA- THAT- THIS THERE'S-
ACTUALLY STAYING HERE THAT
WERE- MAINTAIN THE STANDARDS
THAT OUR STATE HAS ESTABLISHED
FOR THE VARIOUS PROFESSIONS.
AND THAT- WE'RE TRYING TO. HELP
THEM GET. A FULL LICENSE SO
THAT- THEY'RE NO LONGER IN.
HAVING A TEMPORARY LICENSE.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION THROUGH THE CHAIR-
YEAH THESE WERE ALL ISSUES THAT
CAME UP WITH AND WE'VE ACTUALLY
TAKEN SOME AMENDMENTS AND ONE
OF THE AMENDMENTS HELPS ADDRESS
SOME OF THIS IS THAT- IF THERE
IS A CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC EXAM
FOR THE APPLICANTS THAT THEY
MUST PASS THAT EXAM BEFORE
GIVEN THEIR TEMPORARY LICENSE
ON THE ISSUE OF THE LENGTH OF
THAT LICENSE IT'S TWELVE MONTHS
AND SO WANTED TO DO IS GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT'S ENOUGH TIME. TO
TRANSITION TO THIS TO ALLOW
THEM TO GET FULL LICENSURE.
CLARIFIED THE TWELVE MONTHS IS
THAT TWELVE MONTHS. T. SO IF
YOU HAVE A TEMPORARY LICENSE IS
ONLY GOOD FOR TWELVE MONTHS
CORRECT RIGHT OKAY. AND THEN-
AND THEN OF COURSE APPRECIATE
THE EXAM PART AND ALSO JUST
SORT OF THAT. AND SO SOMEONE
WHO IS LICENSED I KNOW HOW
PAINFUL IT CANBE TOO SORRY I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND PERHAPS
THE FRUSTRATION OF THE SPOUSE
OR THE OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
THAT THEY MAY HAVE BUT THAT.
THEY ARE MAKING PROGRESS
TOWARDS GETTING THE FULL
LICENSE THAT IN TERMS OF. THE
VARIOUS PIECES OF PAPER AND
DOCUMENTATION SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PENN COLLEGE ANY OTHER
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS. SEEING NONE. A
FAMILY MEMBER SOLACE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU. I'D
INVITE A MOTION ON ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE ZERO SIX SEVEN SENATOR
DODD HAS MOVED THE BILL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFERRED THE
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
AB ONE ZERO SEVENTY PASSING
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE SPEAK YOUR VOTE INTO
YOUR MICROPHONE ROSS HI. ROSS
I'M MELINDA'S ARCHULETA BEATS.
BEATS I BACKER DODD DAUGHTER HI
ADNAN HER TADO FURTADO I'D
JONES JONES I. LEIVA LEAVE A
ICEMAN. NEW MEN BUT SHOW A
VOGUE PAN CAN I. BILL HAS SEVEN
VOTES WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR. SO MY MEMBER
GARCIA ARE YOU PRESENTING ON
ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE ONE ONE ZERO
SEVEN MEMBER FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REAVIS. YES SIR MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- I'M HERE
TO PRESENT A B. ELEVEN TEN ON
BEHALF OF SOME NUMBER ROBERT
RIVAS THIS BILL WILL CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN FREE
ACCELERATOR PROGRAM WHICH WILL
PROVIDE. THE SINGLE POINT OF
CONNECTION WITHIN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS PURCHASE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE WE DO HAVE-
DAVID WEISS COFF ON THE LINE
THAT WILL BE TESTIFYING HE
REPRESENTS MEXICAN POLICY. THE
STRESS OF MR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
BUILD UP OR OTHER INTERESTS OR
C. AS WELL- THANK MADDIE STAFF
FURTHER PROPAGATION INSISTENT
ON STILL MY NAME IS DAVID
WHITE. I AM WITH NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA. NEXT IN WORKS FOR
PROGRESSIVE POLICY CHANGE TO
ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC INEQUITIES
IN CALIFORNIA. THIS STILL
RESPONDS TO NEED SHARED BY MANY
SMALLER PUBLIC ENTITIES INCLUDE
SCHOOLS FOR A TENTATIVE RURAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT SMALL
MUNICIPALITIES AND OTHERS ISN'T
IT DECENCY THE POTENTIAL COST
SAVINGS AND HEALTH BENEFITS
FROM ADOPTING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. BUT MANY LACK ACCESS
TO THE TYPES OF RESOURCES AND
STAFFING CAPACITY- THAT ARE
NEEDED TO REALLY CONFIDENTLY
MOVE FORWARD. FOR THESE
EDUCATED CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE
EQUIPMENT FOR THEIR NEEDS.
IDENTICAL VEHICLES TO NEGOTIATE
A GOOD PRICE. FOR TO GAIN
ACCESS TO LOW COST CAPITAL AND
THEY MAY NOT HAVE STAFF
AVAILABLE TO PURSUE AVAILABLE
FUNDING AND IN KIND OF
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE STATE
HAS MADE AVAILABLE. ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES MEANS BRINGING
THE SAME KINDS OF TOOLS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO LARGER CITIES
AND COUNTY GOVERNMENTS TO THE
REST OF THE STATE PUBLIC EXCUSE.
THERE ARE THREE PRIMARY
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL FIRST IT
CREATES AN OMBUDSPERSON OFFICE
TO MEET OUTREACH TO ENTITIES
THAT CAN BENEFIT FROM THIS TYPE
OF ASSISTANCE. AND TO CONNECT
THEM WITH AVAILABLE STATE
RESOURCES AND PEER LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. SECOND IT
LEVERAGES COMBINED BUYING POWER
TO DRIVE COST REDUCTIONS. AND
PROVIDE GREATER CERTAINTY TO
EMERGING MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
DURING THIS VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS. THIRD IT CREATES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MOBILIZE
SIGNIFICANT PRIVATE CAPITAL
THAT MAY NOT OTHERWISE BE
AVAILABLE WITHOUT THIS TYPE OF
STATEMENT PROCESS. THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED TO HELP SMALL AND
RURAL TOWNS SCHOOLS AND TRANSIT
OPERATORS SAVE MONEY WHILE ALSO
GAINING ACCESS TO CLEAN
VHICLES FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SIR LET'S NOW
TURN TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AND SUPPORT I SEE NO
WITNESSES IDENTIFYING
THEMSELVES THERE ARE OTHER
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
THIS MEASURE SAYING NONE LET'S
TURN TO THE TELECONFERENCING
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ONE ONE
ZERO WE WILL BEGIN. THE
DENTICULATE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. ONE ONE ONE
ZERO. PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. JUST A MOMENT. THE
PERSON GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
STEVEN JIMENEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION PART
OF EIGHTY ONE ONE ZERO ONE ONE
ONE ZERO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. JUST ONE
MOMENT. LIKE TO GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS THAT CATHY CARRIAGE
AND VENETIA CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT FOR THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. AT THE TIME THERE'S NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION FIRST OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IDENTIFYING THEMSELVES LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE I
SEE NO ONE THERE LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD ONCE
AGAIN PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE ONE ONE ZERO WE WILL BEGIN.
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. ONE ONE ONE
ZERO. IN A PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE STANDARDS NOTING
Q. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
LET'S. BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE. SOME REMEMBER
GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. MAY I
HAVE A MOTION ON ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE ONE ONE ZERO. MOTION BY
SENATOR HER TITLE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THREE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB A
LEVANTINE DEPRESSING REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION ROSS.
ROSS I MELINDA'S ARCHULETA
BEATS. BEATS I BACKER DODD DOT
HI A MAN. HER TADO FURTADO I
JONES. JONES I. LEIVA LEAVE
ICEMAN NEWMAN BUT SHOW A BOGE.
HAN CAN I BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR.
THINGS WERE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALLS. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE AND
PLEASE READ. FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY SIX NINETY MULLIN-
CURRENT VOTE NINE TO ZERO
MELINDA'S. HER TADO HER TADO
ALRIGHT LISA LEAVE A HI UNTIL A
BOGEY. PAN CAN I. PHOTOS TWELVE
ZERO WILL HOLD THAT MATTER OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE IT IT
Q. EIGHTY FOURTEEN OH SEVEN
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO ONE.
MELINDA'S HER TADO HER TADO I
LEAVE US. LEAVE THAT HI BUT
SHOW ABODE HAND. CAN I- VOTE
ELEVEN TO ONE WILL HOLD THAT
MATTER OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FIVE OH EIGHT M. THREE A. B.
SIX NINE ONE CURRENT VOTE NINE
TWO ZERO MELINDA'S. HER TADO
HER TADO HI LISA LEAVE A I A
CHOU ABODE PAN. CAN I. KURD
VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO WILL HOLD
THAT MATTER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. FILE ITEM TEN EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY CURRENT VOTE NINE
TWO ZERO MELINDA'S HER TADO.
HER TADO I'D LEAVE US LEAVE AT
NIGHT A SHOW ABOUT O. CAN CAN
I CURRENT VOTE TWELVE ZERO WILL
HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. FILE ITEM. FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR SIX EIGHT CURRENT VOTE
NINE TWO ZERO MELINDA'S. HER
TADO. HER TADO HI LISA LEAVE A
I. A CHU A BOGEY. A CHORE BOGUE
ITN CAN I
- THIRTEEN ZERO.
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS A.
FILE ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY TWO TWO
NINE CURRENTVOTE EIGHT ZERO
MELINDA'S HER TADO. HER TADO
I'D JONES. LLEVA. LEAVE A HI I
HAVE A SHOW ABOUT OKAY. A SHOW
ABOUT I. P. N. HE AND I. THE
SERVER IS TWELVE ZERO THAT
MATTERS OUT. FILE ITEM EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE FOUR EIGHT CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT TO ONE HER TADO
MELINDA'S HER TADO. HER TADO II
LEVER LEAVE A I A SHOW A BOGE.
BUT SHOW A BOGUS IPN. CAN I.
VOTE TWELVE ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT. FILE ITEM NINE AB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN CURRENT VTE EIGHT
TWO ZERO MELINDA'S. EIGHT HER
TADO HER TADO I'D LEAVE A.
LEAVE A HI A CHOU ABODE UNTIL A
BOGEY I CAN. HE AND I.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT THEY.
VOTERS TWELVE ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT. YOU CONSENTS AB TEN SEVEN
TWO THE CURRENT VOTE IS NINE
TWO ZERO MELINDA'S. HER TADO
HER TADO HI LISA LEAVE US HI A
SHOW ABOUT OKAY. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THAT SHOW VOGUE I CAN.
CAN I. VOTERS THIRTEEN ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. FILE
ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
ONE CURRENT VOTE NINE TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S BEATS. HER TADO. HER
TADO II JONES JONES HI LISA
LEAVE A I. THE VOTE S TWELVE
ZERO ON THAT ITEM WE WILL HOLD
THAT ITEM OPEN. PHYLUM. TWELVE
EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY TWO CURRENT
VOTE NINE TWO ZERO MELINDA'S.
ARCHULETA HER TADO HER TADO I'D
JONES. MAN. FILE ITEM. TWELVE
EIGHTY FIVE SIX TWO. MAN I. THE
VOTE ON THAT ITEM IS ELEVEN
DOES ZERO. WE'LL HOLD THAT I
ITEM OPEN AS WELL. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TWO Q.
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA EGGMAN.
EIGHT MEN I HER TADO. JONES.
JONES NO MAN. NEWMAN NEW MAN I.
THE VOTE IS- SEVENTY THREE ON
THAT MEASURE WE WILL HOLD THEM
OUT OF THAT ITEM OPEN. FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN
OH TWO CURRENT VOTE FOR TWO
ZERO. MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA BAIT.
BACKER EIGHT MEN. AIKMAN HI HER
TADO. HER TADO NO JONES JONES
NARROW NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI A SHOW
ABOUT. A SHOW ABOUT A GUY CAN.
THE CURRENT VOTERS- SEVEN TO
TWO WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB ONE ZERO
SEVEN CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO MELINDA'S ARCHULETA.
BACKER BACKER I'D EIGHT MILLION
EIGHT MEN I MEAN I MEAN I
NEWMAN NEW MAN I I'D SHOW ABODE.
A TURBO GUY. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I. THIRD. VOTE ON
THAT ITEM IS THIRTEEN ZERO THAT
MATTER IS OUT. FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB ELEVEN TEN CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA HI MELINDA IS REGULAR
BECKER. BECKER I ADMIN EIGHT
MIN I MAN MAN I KNEW MAN. NEW
MAN I I'D SHOW A BOGUS. THAT
SHOW A VOGUE HI. THIRTEEN ZERO
THAT MATTERS OF.
MEMBERS
RELIVING THE CALLS FOR THE LAST
TIME AND WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
OUT THE ROLE SO. MADAM DIRECTOR
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX NINETY
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. BUT SHOW A BOGEY. A
SHOW ABOUT. THIRTEEN ZERO THE
BILLS OUT YOU DO YOUR JOB. FILE
M. Q. A. B. FOURTEEN OH SEVEN
CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN TO ONE
MELINDA'S. I CHOSE A BOGEY. I
CHOSE BOTH BY BOOK TWELVE ONE
THAT BUILDS A. FILE ITEM THREE
EIGHTY SIX NINE ONE CURRENT
VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO MELINDA'S.
A CHILL ABODE. A TRUE ABOAGYE.
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT MATTERS A.
FILE ITEM TEN EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO
ZERO MELINDA'S. BUT SHOW A
BOGEY. A TERRIBLE GUY. THIRTEEN
ZERO THAT MATTER IS A- FILE
ITEM. EIGHT EIGHTY NINE FORTY
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TO
ONE. MELINDA'S HOPE SORRY WE'RE
ON. CORRECT STOP VERY CLOSE THE
ROLE. IT'S FIVE ITEM. TWELVE
EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY TWO CURRENT
VOTE ELEVEN TWO ZERO MELINDA'S.
ARCHULETA CHILLOUT ICE JONES.
IT'S TWELVE TO ZERO IN THE- TWO
ZERO THAT MATTER IS OUT. FILE
ITEM. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
TO THREE MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA EYED HER TADO. MAN.
THAT VOTE IS. EIGHTY THREE.
THAT MATTER IS OUT. FALLON IN.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH TWO
CURRENT BOATS SEVEN TWO TWO
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I'D BEAT BACKER CAN. A VOTE IS
EIGHT TO TWO THAT MATTER IS OUT.
YOU CAN JUST CLOSE THE MATTER-
FILE ITEM. ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
SEVEN ONE. NO ONE DOES B.
TWELVE ZERO THAT MATTER IS OUT.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THANKS TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. INCLUDES OUR
AGENDA IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS.
IN WRITING TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR PLEASE VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. OF
TODAY WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. X. AGAIN TO ALL
WHO PARTICIPATED WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IS ADJOURNED.